Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So, da bin ich, Leute.
Am Start.
So, jetzt.
Moin Michael, 50 Billion.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Exzellent, dich mal wieder hier im Stream zu sehen.
Heute jetzt auch schon am Start.
Ja, Leute.
Heute mal wieder aufwachen im Stream.
Ja, ganz ungewohnt mittlerweile schon.
Ich habe glaube ich schon 2 oder 3 Wochen
keinen Aufwachen Stream mehr gemacht.
Ich bin nicht mehr kurz afgklo.
Wollen wir vielleicht ein bisschen kleiner machen.
Und Chat, wie war die erste Woche für euch?
Also für mich war die erste Woche tatsächlich recht entspannt.
also ich bin hier ich war jeden tag in frankfurt diese woche von dienstag bis
freitag jeden tag die kantine gegangen peter fett gemacht
kantine ist halt kantine ist halt echt weiß bei uns das ist subventioniert und du kriegst
dafür so ungefähr sieben euro so in dem dreh kostet immer am tag sieben euro kriegst du
Ein Hauptgericht, einmal trinken, ein richtig vollgeladener Salatteller und danach noch ein Blaubeermuffin.
Den hol ich mir da immer noch in der Cafeteria.
Und das alles für irgendwie 57 bis 58, das schwankt immer je nachdem was man isst.
Aber das ist echt, da kann man wirklich nichts dagegen sagen.
Das ist wirklich pog.
Very pog.
So, jetzt machen wir mal kurz die VM an und installieren Updates.
Ich hatte seit Ewigkeiten heute Morgen einen Crash auf meinem Desktop hier.
Irgendwas mit Netzwerktreibern, Blue Screen.
Wobei der Blue Screen gar nicht mehr Blue ist, der ist jetzt Black.
Black Screen.
Da steht dann irgendwas da von wegen Netzstreiber, irgendwelche Probleme, Rechner muss neu gestartet werden.
Das ist der Hedge.
package updates captcha hat wieder nicht richtig übrigens erinnert jetzt wo es
hier gerade sehen erinnert sich noch einer wo wir hier
bisschen rust gebastelt haben in letzter zeit ich habe mich doch so so
angestellt im stream eine vibe coded library zu benutzen falls sich da noch
irgendjemand daran erinnert ich habe die jetzt ausprobiert weil es irgendwie das
einzige ist in rust was auch für terminal output gescheit und ist gar
nicht so schlecht obwohl es weib code ist ich habe sogar getappt ich habe
sogar auf github ein feature feature request eingereicht hier
für die Library.
Hier.
Nämlich, dass man den Spinner-Style
bei einer Progress-Bar setzen kann.
Ich hab das auch, also ich hab das aus
zwei Gründen gemacht. Ja, ich möchte, dass
diese Library ordentlich maintained wird
und Issues und Sachen
und so,
das motiviert
Library-Maintainer, gerade wenn es
was Neues ist. Es gibt nichts Unmotivierendes,
wie du pushst was, was eigentlich
ganz gut ist, die Leute benutzen,
sagen aber nix und du denkst halt, es kommt nicht
gut an. Und nach einem halben Jahr
oder paar Wochen hast du keinen Bock mehr.
Wie es geht? Eigentlich ganz gut.
Und deswegen habe ich hier ein
Feature-Request erstellt.
Und
er hat auch schon ein Pull-Request
erstellt für den Feature-Request.
Jetzt wollte ich mal gucken, ob der auch
vibecoded ist, der Pull-Request.
Jetzt gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal, ob das auch vibecoded ist.
Check. 16 Checks.
What the fuck, Alter?
Okay.
Files changed. 21 Files.
Wie?
So ein Feature.
21 Files. Krass.
Allspin. Eine neue Demo.
Das ist 100 pro vibecoded.
Keiner würde das je so ordentlich machen.
Lol, lulala.
Keiner würde das je so ordentlich mit
Examples und Readme und Docs machen.
Das ist 100% wieder Vibecode.
Ist ja nicht schlimm, solange es funktioniert.
Soll mir das recht sein.
Ach guck mal, der Vibe codet mit, weiß ich nicht, Opus oder so oder Gemini und dann mit Copilot gibt's, gibt's, gibt's Comments und das reagiert dann da auch drauf oder wie?
Alter, der hat, hat, hat gewipe codet hier.
Hardcore Vibe codet.
Naja.
Ja.
Jetzt das Spiel The Farmer was replaced.
Ne, was ist das?
Ach doch, das, ne das kenn ich nicht.
Ich kenn aber sowas ähnliches, wo du Roboter-Firmware entwickeln sollst.
Game.
Ja.
Das kenn ich nicht.
Hier.
solcher dinger
jeder kann man übertreiben weiß aber nicht ich es gibt ja einige es gibt
einige solcher spiele bis jetzt habe ich hat es mich noch nie da so hingezogen so
ich habe davon auch nie irgendwas aus vielleicht taugt das ja echt
ich mache nicht überall im ort schießt ich mache twitch e-mails das was anderes
wurde im urlaub eigentlich wieder hart reingezockt es geht so also das einzige
was ich in letzter zeit spieler bis hier
das da
da bin ich jetzt anfang akt 3 ich werde nichts dazu sagen weil spoiler
spoiler spoiler
aber das ist nicht schlecht warum das jetzt so krass viele gamer game of the
gewonnen hat weiß ich auch nicht also alle hätte auch nicht gebraucht das
schon gutes game aber das jetzt nicht besser aller zeiten oder so
doch zwar immer updates
heckmann
toolbox
ist sehr schön hat sechs bach schon wieder egal update mir trotzdem schein
trotzdem noch zu gehen ob obwohl session expired ist. Yes, update, update, update.
Lass wir den mal rödeln da im Hintergrund.
Das dauert jetzt. Wobei, nö, hier guck mal. Wobei, ich hätte runter scrollen sollen.
geht er eigentlich wie es geht ganz okay ganz okay
welcher window manager und welche terminal emulator ist das das ist
i3 also ist noch unter x das kein wayland stellt weil das
wayland funst mit tiling window manager nicht richtig unter unter vm
und das terminal ist west herr meiner meinung nach das beste terminal was zurzeit gibt unter linux
Wetzterm.
Westerb hier, das da.
Beste.
Wie viele Sterne hatten das eigentlich mittlerweile?
Ich hoffe ordentlich.
Okay, jetzt muss ich erstmal kurz vergleichen.
23 mit Kitty.
Ich finde das deutlich besser als Kitty.
Kitty hat 30k.
Ah gut.
Weil Kitty hat das Problem mit...
Gateway is running.
Achso, ich hab hier noch Thrust-Zeug auf.
Ekel.
Weil Kitty hat Probleme mit T-Mux.
Und das kann ich natürlich nicht haben, so oft wie ich remote aufs System drauf bin.
Aller Kitty hat ganz viele Sachen nicht, wie zum Beispiel Terminal-Support.
Wobei, weiß ich nicht, hat alle Kitty mittlerweile Image-Support?
Und Tabs und sowas?
Also Tabs und Splits und solche Dinger?
also ich finde ich finde insgesamt feature feature war es so was satz wieder eine güte
also von features her finde ich finde ich west das beste was gibt außerdem außerdem west herrn
placing lief fast ritten in rust ja nicht dass es einen irgendwie interessieren müsste in was
ein Terminal programmiert ist.
So.
Reboot.
Haben wir alles geupdatet?
Ja. Bam.
Ghosty habe ich mir nicht angeguckt.
War Ghosty nicht dieses AI-Stell-Terminal?
Ne.
Ne. Das war was anderes.
so start x guckt mir sind auch unter x unterwegs
war ist das genau genau jetzt wo du sagst war hieß das stellt wo man sich einloggen muss ganz
ehrlich wenn ich wenn ich ein login brauche für man terminal dann ist echt vorbei das sehe ich
nicht ein übrigens gibt was neues wollte ich eigentlich gestern streamen aber ich habe mich
zu sehr dran dran festgehängt zum basteln ich habe roxmox installiert lokal ich habe
Ich habe hier so einen Mini-PC.
Ich glaube, dieses Teil hier.
Genau.
Und noch so einen Mini-PC.
Den will ich jetzt endlich nicht als finale Kiste für einen Proxmox-Server verwenden.
Aber ohne euch, ja.
Okay, das ist ja, glaube ich, so ziemlich das beschissenste Bild für eine Kiste überhaupt.
Gibt es da nicht ein gescheites Bild von?
Ne, die haben es sich gedacht.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Scheites Bild von, ja okay
Das ist so ein Mini, übrigens
Mega hässliche Farbe
Ich hab ja schon
Kram laufen, ne, ich hab ja
Ich hab ja einen HP Microserver
Mit Unraid drauf, da läuft
Home Assistant drauf und noch ein paar andere Sachen
Paperless brauch ich nicht, noch ein paar andere Sachen
Aber irgendwie bin ich
Von Anfang an nie so richtig
Mit Unraid zufrieden gewesen
Das
Das kann zwar alles, ja
Von NAS bis
docker images bis vor ems aber irgendwie finde ich das interface so keine ahnung
ist das gefällt mir nicht erinnert mich an alte tv head and version so ein
bisschen so und jetzt dachte ich mir so okay weißt du was max guck dir doch
einfach mal box an und jetzt habe ich das darauf installiert wirklich billig
ja also da ist ein 1 terabyte nvme ssd trainer nix sonst also das viel habe ich viel was der
fs angeht und so kann man damit nicht ausbringen ich mache noch eine zweite informieren für bis
zum zfs zum basteln android ja ja das ist das nächste ich habe zwar noch so eine lifetime für
immer lizenz android kostet mittlerweile 49 49 euro im jahr glaube ich und 230 euro lifetime
Warte mal.
Warte mal hier.
Products. Pricing.
Hier.
Genau. 49 Dollar. Nicht Euro.
Wobei, ich glaube,
das kommt ungefähr
aufs Gleiche raus.
Also, 49
Dollar im Jahr
kostet das? Also es ist
halt ein bisschen blöd gemacht, ne?
Du musst das zwar nur, hier steht zwar
groß One Time, aber
du kriegst so ein Jahr Updates.
So, und dann, okay, du kriegst
halt ein bisschen
günstiger dann, wenn du es...
Also sagen wir so, okay, sind wir mal nett,
es kostet dich 36 Dollar
im Jahr, okay?
36 Dollar im Jahr, weil
du willst ja weiterhin Updates bekommen, ohne
Updates ist ja ziemlich Sack.
Ich behaupte mal, das hier reicht für so gut wie jeden.
Also ich bin der Meinung, entweder...
Entweder das, oder man kann gleich das kaufen.
Das hier weiß ich nicht so, wo der Sinn davon ist.
Also, prompt.
Ja, genau so fühlt sich das auch für mich an.
Die UI ist wirklich 2000er Hobbyprojekt.
Das ist zwar nice, dass das alles kann.
Und ich finde auch den Ansatz, wie sie da ihre NAS-Funktionalität gebaut haben, ziemlich gut.
Ich habe auch noch die alte Lizenz, die die Lifetime für ein paar Dollar war.
Ja, aber das UI ist echt nix.
Wie klickt man eigentlich Battlefield-Icon?
Twitch.
Also das
UI gefällt mir halt auch überhaupt nicht.
Also ich mag, also ich finde
gut, ich finde gut in
Unraid,
wie sie ihre
Nass-Funktionalität gemacht haben. Das finde ich
eigentlich so für Homelab-Geschichten mit
am besten. In Unraid haben sie es ja so
gemacht, das ist so ein bisschen
selbstgestrickt von denen, ja.
Also in Unraid kannst
ja unterschiedlich viele Platten einbauen,
wie du so willst. So, sag mal,
baust du zwei, drei Platten ein, dann kannst du
so eine Art RAID
darüber machen, wobei das
also das ist kein
klassisches RAID,
die
haben da irgendwas eigenes implementiert.
Das ist dann so ähnlich wie RAID 5
kannst du damit bauen und RAID 1.
Und zumindest können die auch
relativ easy ein SSD-Cache
hinzufügen.
Es funktioniert folgendermaßen,
Das ist so eine Art Overlay-File-System.
Also sprich, man hat hier seine Festplatten, man hat seine SSD und die werden zusammengefasst zu einem Directory.
Also der SSD-Content wird overlaid über die HDDs.
Also letztendlich siehst du alles nur einmal. Es ist ähnlich wie MergerFS, genau. Es ist nicht MergerFS, sagen die auch, aber es ist so ähnlich wie MergerFS. Das wird quasi Overlayed. Du hast hier den Inhalt aus deinem HDD-Rate und deinem SSD-Cache in einem Directory.
Letztendlich weißt du nicht, wenn du hier auf dieser Ebene guckst, wo die Daten liegen, ob auf der SSD oder auf der HDD.
Dementsprechend haben die es auch so gemacht, dass neue Files immer erst auf der SSD erstellt werden, was halt sauschnell ist, wenn du Dateien dahin kopierst.
Und dann alle paar Stunden oder so werden die Daten unter der Haube von der SSD gemoved.
Das ist letztendlich ein Find und ein Move oder ein R-Sync oder sowas.
Das ist nichts großartig kompliziertes.
von hier auf die HDDs
und nachdem du ja immer nur
dieses View von oben hast, wo beide
gemerged sind, fällt dir das gar nicht auf.
So. Also das ist vom
Ansatz her eigentlich ziemlich cool,
wie die das machen bei Unraid.
Man kann sich so was
selbst bauen, das ist nicht das Ding, weil man könnte
zum Beispiel sagen, wir nehmen hier
Wiff, wo wir es gerade davon hatten, man nimmt das hier,
das ist auch so ein Union
File, nicht Overlay, Union File System
ist da ein richtiges Wort für, genau.
Man nimmt das,
ja, damit könnte man das auch machen,
man könnte beispielsweise sagen,
hier, seine HDDs,
macht man einen ZFS-Rate
oder einen
BTFS-Rate oder einen
LVM oder irgendwie sowas,
dann macht man eine SSD und dann
macht man da Merger-FS drüber und
movt das manuell einmal nächtlich
mit einem Skript oder so. Das kann man alles selbst
bauen, so was Unraid da gemacht hat,
aber ich finde es halt ganz gut integriert deswegen finde ich die nass
nass seit ich finde ich android fürs homelab eigentlich am besten
also wir haben auch schon mal auf media volt und schulers und so ausprobiert
aber irgendwie finde ich vom ansatz her so für für heim homelab sachen android
eigentlich am besten.
Du hast natürlich
bei dieser Sache nicht den Vorteil,
glaube ich, glaube ich, bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
wie es unter der Haube funktioniert, du hast nicht
den Vorteil von einem echten
Raid.
Also,
du hast zum Beispiel keine beschleunigten
Reads und sowas.
Also,
du hast dann nicht, also,
wenn du nur Raid, bei angenommen, du hast nur Raid 1,
Raid 1 ist ein Spiegel über zwei Platten,
Also sprich, wenn du was schreibst, wird das auf beide Platten geschrieben und wenn eine Platte ausfällt, dann, sagen wir mal, merkst du davon nichts.
So, und ich glaube, so wie die das machen... Achso, ja, wenn du liest von dem Raid 1, kannst du ja... Oh gut, dann kannst du es auch machen.
okay dann das aber neu oder neue ja weil ich habe eine uralte version weil ich zu faul war
zum updaten ich glaube wir das nicht mit zettel und bei der red 1 kannst du ja wenn du liest
doppelt lesen von beiden planen ja du liest die erste hälfte der datei von der einen platte und
die zweite hälfte von der anderen platte jetzt mal so ist es nicht das ist ja blockweise aber
du hast mit einem red 1 hast du im endeffekt potenziell doppelt so schnell wie geschwindigkeit
aber halt nur einfache ride geschwindigkeit so was hast du dabei der standard an raid sachen
glaube ich nicht aber ich finde trotzdem fürs home lab super gibt es gibt es nichts zu sagen
also nass mäßig finde ich die den ansatz von von android eicher besten für für daheim ja
vom home lab mäßig leider ist das handling von docker container und vms ich finde es so hakelig
in Unraid.
Und auch wie man da das Netzwerk
konfiguriert. Ich finde das so
hakelig. Du brauchst auch einige Addons, wo du
dann teilweise nicht weißt, ob die Dinger noch in einem Jahr
supported werden. Also irgendwie,
letztendlich, es ist ein vollwertiges Linux
unter Unraid. Es ist aber kein Debian
oder sonst was. Es ist irgendein
Slackware, ist es glaube ich, unter Unraid
drunter. Das heißt, du hast auch keinen normalen
Package Manager und musst dir zusätzliche Sachen per
Tag EZ runterladen und sowas.
Das ist, ah.
Ich weiß nicht. Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht,
Ich installiere mir einfach hier mal eine Runde Proxmox drauf und probiere das aus.
Das können wir auch im Streamer mal machen dann, wenn ich mir das ein bisschen angeguckt habe.
Und ich muss sagen, das Handling von VMs und Containern ist um Längen besser als unter Unraid mit Proxmox.
Das wundert aber auch nicht. Proxmox ist ja hauptsächlich auf VMs ausgelegt.
container ist aber halt auch wieder so ein halbes ding android unterstützt halt ganz normal docker
container lxc schwarzen android docker boxbox unterstützt eigentlich lxc container seit neuestem
kann man docker images verwenden aber es ist trotzdem kein docker das wird umgewandelt lxc
Images. Da weiß ich nicht,
ob das so geil ist. Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Deswegen,
und das habe ich
die ganze Zeit eh schon vor,
weil das Docker-Handling in Android
auch nicht so geil ist, wollte ich
eigentlich
DocBlue bei mir lokal verwenden
für meine ganzen
Docker-Container-Hosting.
Was hat er denn hier runtergeladen
jetzt gerade?
GitHub, was ist da los?
Naja, deswegen wollte ich mir
eigentlich hier installieren
für meine Docker-Container.
So, das werde ich,
im Endeffekt wird es dann darauf rauslaufen,
ich installiere meine VM für diese
Geschichte
in Proxmox
und da mache ich dann mal ganzes Docker-Zeug drauf mit einem ordentlichen
Web-Interface und so ein paar
Basic Sachen werde ich vielleicht
in einem LXC Container installieren.
Zum Beispiel in Zabbix für mein Monitoring
haue ich in einen LXC Container rein.
Ja.
Wow, die Musik ist viel lauter. Was ist da los?
Warum ist die Musik auf einmal so laut?
MonkaS.
Jetzt wieder leiser.
Das mag ich, wenn Playlisten so nicht normalized sind.
So.
Ja, aber so sieht es aus.
Das habe ich mir angeguckt.
Auf GitHub.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr aus dem Kopf.
Irgendwas hat mir da dran
gefehlt, warum ich
gesagt habe, Doc Ploy ist dann doch nicer.
Ich weiß es aber nicht mehr was. Ich habe es mir
angeguckt. Das ist ja noch relativ neu.
Komodo.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was es war.
kann doch auch docker kompost ja ja ja deine meinung zu federer
ich kann aktuell überhaupt nichts zu sagen ich habe lange nicht nicht wirklich benutzt
also kann ich nichts zu sagen also ich bin ich benutze das eigentlich so gut wie nicht
deswegen kann ich dazu aktuellen federer version gar nichts sagen
wie findest du es im vergleich zu vm wäre ja also ganz ehrlich wenn man jetzt mal ein bisschen
keck business enterprise von ausgeht da wirkt boxbox doch noch etwas rudimentärer als vor
mw ich meine vor er hat halt auch jahrzehnte ökosystem drumherum mit zertifizierung und
leute die sich auf vmware spezialisiert haben blablub also ich denke für wirklich große
business enterprise geschichten ist vor mw nach wie vor das ding schlechthin wenn man jetzt mal
so klein und mittel sich angucken auch kein bock hat auf broadcom lizenzierung und sowas und
vielleicht auch nicht noch nicht so sehr in diesem vor allem ökosystem drin ist dann ist das sicherlich nicht verkehrt
Ja, also wenn jetzt sagen wir mal hier die lokale Schreinerei oder Bäcker oder so mit fünf Filialen, die ein bisschen Technik brauchen, wenn du da was virtualisieren willst, dann würde ich garantiert nicht mit VMware heutzutage anfangen.
Ja, oder irgendwie eine Werbeagentur, die ein paar Services lokal braucht.
Also, den würde ich nicht vor allem aufs Auge drücken.
Wo ich mir nicht ganz sicher bin, das habe ich auch noch nicht durchstiegen bei Proxmox, wie das mit den Backups gescheit funktioniert.
also Backups selbst von Containern und so ist überhaupt kein Ding, das ist recht easy.
Von Containern und von VMs, das ist relativ easy.
Ich frage mich, wie gut man das System selbst backuppen kann.
Oder ob man das nach Möglichkeit möglichst stateless halten sollte,
sodass man das einfach neu installiert und die VM-Backups wieder zurückspielt.
Aber das kann ich ja alles ausprobieren auf meiner kleinen Mini-PC-Kiste.
Aber lohnt es sich ein Unternehmen auf Proxmox?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe keine praktische Erfahrung mit Proxmox, was das Business-mäßig angeht.
Kein Schimmer.
Und es ist jetzt auch nicht so, als ist Virtualisierung so mein Steckenpferd.
Ich habe auf der Arbeit auch so gut wie keine Schnittmenge mit VMware.
Das einzige, was ich da mache, ist ab und zu meine Festplatte vergrößern oder mehr RAM reinhauen oder eine Kiste neu starten über dieses vSphere Web Interface.
Das hält sich in Grenzen. Ich habe auch nie großartige VMware Sachen administriert.
Gibt es eigentlich sowas wie...
Also so einen Cluster Manager für Hyper-V?
Also so ein Gegenstück zu VMware?
weil Hyper-V habe ich im Kopf, ist immer so ein Ding. Das hast du halt auf einem Windows-Server
drauf, wenn du da mal in die missliche Lage kommst, dass du irgendwie was virtualisieren
musst und dann ist gut. Ich wüsste halt auch nicht, warum man Hyper-V verwendet.
Wahrscheinlich, wenn man ganz viel Windows virtualisieren muss,
dann ist wahrscheinlich Hyper-V nicht verkehrt.
Wobei ich auch selbst da sagen würde, Linux ist ja nicht prinzipiell schlecht mit Windows-Virtualisierung.
Ich könnte mir aber vorstellen, dass Windows unter Windows-Virtualisierung mit Hyper-V Donner und Dicken besser ist,
weil das ist schon ein bisschen stiefmütterlich im Vergleich zu Linux.
Ja, Linux unter Linux, das ist ja, also da hast du ja Performance und Resource Usage ist ja,
du hast ja da kaum Overhead mittlerweile, ja.
Also du hast ja auch super schnell alles, was Netzwerk und Disk-IO und sowas angeht in der VM.
Linux unter Linux.
Jonas hat seine ganzen Kisten auf Hyper-V.
Ach ja, ich habe einen Server bei Jonas.
Einen 1 Euro im Monat Server.
Den habe ich hauptsächlich, weil er eine feste IPv4-Adresse hat.
Und das finde ich eigentlich ganz nice.
und praktisch.
Ich glaube, der ist sogar ausgeschaltet mittlerweile.
Ich glaube, den habe ich nicht mal mehr an.
Dass ich den nicht updaten muss und sowas.
Aber den behalte ich.
Hätte ich nicht gedacht,
dass sie das auf Hyper-V laufen haben.
Ritzcool, moin.
Hast du dich umbenannt?
Ja, was mich bei Proxmox noch interessiert, wie ich einfach nach, mal angenommen, mein Proxmox-System geht kaputt.
Zum Beispiel, weil ich aus Versehen per SSH eingeloggt war und RM-RF gemacht habe oder sowas.
könnte ja sein könnte ja sein wie kriege ich das wieder restored also reicht es wenn ich
einfach ein usb-signal und proxmox neu drauf installieren xd wurdest du gebannt hast du
neue account machen musst reicht es wenn ich dann per usb einfach proxmox wieder installieren und
sagt, hier guck mal, da sind da
alte Platten.
Das reicht ja nicht, weil diese ganzen
VM-Configs und sowas,
die sind ja auf der
Proxmox-Platte drauf.
Ja.
das muss ich mal ausbringen, aber das werde ich auf meinem Mini-PC
alles ausbringen
ja
selbst Cluster können crashen und sonst was
also insofern, man muss schon gucken
dass man die Sache wieder restoren kann
ja, ja, aber wie restorest du das?
wie restorest du das? mal angenommen
du machst aus Versehen
rm-rf auf deinem Proxmox.
So, du hast Backups
von den VMs,
aber du musst ja Proxmox neu installieren.
Und die
Config von Proxmox.
Da ist nämlich nichts eingebaut
Backup-technisch für den ganzen Node.
Das muss ich ausprobieren.
Also,
VM-Backup ist easy.
Kannst du im Webinterface anlegen.
So.
Ich habe schon mal rr-rf aus Versehen gemacht,
im falschen Verzeichnis, ja.
Das habe ich schon gemacht.
Einmal habe ich das gemacht.
Aus Versehen.
Vertippt.
Beziehungsweise im falschen Verzeichnis.
Das war es gelöscht.
Ja, das habe ich schon geschafft.
So, dann gucken wir uns doch mal GitHub Trends an.
Ja, das ist auch geil.
m-fr französischen Sprachpakete deinstalliert.
Macht den Rechner viel schneller.
Äh, Trend?
Trending Weekly, lass mich raten.
AI, AI, AI, AI, AI.
Omcode.
Open Code habe ich auch am Start.
Aber.
Ist das das Open Code?
Ja, auch die Readme sah doch anders aus.
Ne, das ist das alte Repo.
Ne, dann ist das das richtige.
ja OpenCode
OpenCode ist mega nice
man kann kostenlos
in OpenCode GLM 4.7 benutzen
Minimax M2.1
und GPT-5 Nano
also für kostenlos
kannst du dich echt nicht beschweren
das ist wirklich ok
OpenCode ist ziemlich
POG
so
AI, AI, AI.
Note-Taking-App.
AI.
AI-Tools.
aha und und und docker container für android
durch zu vollkommen bald glm 5 und die ps4 hat es kam doch erst vor ein paar wochen glm 4.7
Vielleicht haben wir Glück und GLM 5
darf man dann den Open Code auch kostenlos benutzen
Ich glaub's ja nicht
Weil eigentlich finde ich GLM 4.7
so insgesamt gar nicht verkehrt
Okay, also irgendwie ist er
So, wir gucken mal was anderes
Wir gucken mal, was in Rust trendet
Leute
Blazingly Fast written in Rust.
Ich glaube nicht, die sind doch an die Börse gegangen.
Aha, okay.
Das habe ich doch so genau, verfolge ich das nicht.
Okay.
Cross-Platform Desktop All-in-One Assistant 2.
Okay, AI.
Git-Butler.
Version-Control-Client.
Das ist wieder sowas.
Seriously, Leute.
Git-UIs.
Useless.
Das Einzige, wie man Git ordentlich verwendet, ist CLI.
Wenn ich das schon sehe, kriege ich Anfälle, Alter.
Hör mal bloß auf!
Danke für den Sub, Pog!
Achso und für den Michael5 Spilian müssen wir auch nochmal hier.
Was haben aber alle gegen Rust? Ich hab nix gegen Rust.
Nutzt das in letzter Zeit sogar
So ein bisschen üben auch
Selbst recht oft
Rust ist halt nicht die schönste Sprache
Das liegt aber in der Natur von Rust
Weil du ganz viele Compile-Time-Checks machen musst
Und das halt ein bisschen Unterstützung braucht
Dass es das machen kann
Das ist tatsächlich
Eines der Dinger
Die ich nicht so gut an Rust finde
da sind sehr viele Missionare unterwegs, die versuchen, alle Leute zu bekehren und so nach dem Motto, mit Rust wäre das nicht passiert und hier und Rust und da und so.
realistisch betrachtet,
muss man ja mal sagen,
Rust ist,
wenn man es mal
so oft,
wenn man es mal versucht, möglichst objektiv zu sehen,
ist Rust
für die wenigsten Projekte
geeignet.
Rust ist richtig gut
für Projekte oder für Software,
die
schnell sein müssen und
die so memory safe wie möglich sein müssen.
Das in Kombination
so schnell wie möglich und so memory safe wie möglich.
Also sowas wie
irgendwelche Sachen in einem Browser.
Die allermeiste Software
profitiert da gar nicht so sehr von.
Also bei der allermeisten Software
ist das nicht schlimm.
Im Zweifel vercrash das Ding mal.
es ist leicht zu heften sage ich gar
nichts dagegen ja also auf jeden fall
gut zu wissen dass ein programm nicht
irgendwelche verdeckten memory probleme
hat so von von memory leaks kannst ja
was auch nicht verhindern aber von
irgendwie use after free oder solche
sehr gut zu wissen ja das nicht verkehrt
aber das bekommst du sagen garbage
kollektive sprachen auch das ist nicht
das ist nicht falsch aber wo es wirklich
essentiell ist, ist halt Software,
wo es drauf ankommt.
Sprich, dass die halt so schnell
sind wie möglich und Memory-Safe
wie möglich. Also mir fällt spontan halt immer
irgendwelche Browser-Geschichten ein.
Browser ist so
ein High-Security-Ding.
Browser führt den ganzen Tag
nur fremden Code aus im Endeffekt.
Und
der muss natürlich auch so schnell sein, wie es geht. Also für solche
Dinge ist Rust gut.
Wo ich es mir in Zukunft
auch gut vorstellen könnte ist microcontroller kram weil das hieß sie
jedoch ganz gerne mal mit c oder gar mit kotzen c++ im fuß das könnte ich mir
vorstellen könnte auf dauer wenn man projekt damit baut die qualität der
firma doch erhöhen aber man muss halt sehen war rast das für die meisten
Projekte geht es ja auch darum, dass man gut vorankommt, also relativ produktiv und schnell ist, da irgendwas zu implementieren und dass die Sprache gut lesbar ist.
So, und da sind wir halt bei Rust teilweise in so einem Bereich, wo man sagen muss, also Rust ist jetzt nicht die schnellste Sprache zu entwickeln.
Das liegt halt daran, weil Rust ganz viele Compile-Time-Checks macht und halt schaut, dass das alles Memory-Safe ist zur Compile-Zeit schon.
überprüfbar dementsprechend musste da schon ein bisschen drum herum springen und gucken
dass was mit deinem code einverstanden ist also produktivität für dich sagen ist in rust jetzt
nicht so hoch wie sagen wir mal in c sharp oder oder sowas es halt das ding und rust ist jetzt
auch nicht unbedingt die schönste Sprache oder die besten lesbare Sprache.
Wenn man es mal wieder mit sowas wie beispielsweise C-Sharp oder Go oder sowas
vergleicht. Also in Go und C-Sharp bist du deutlich schneller im entwickeln, hast
auch keine Memory Probleme, du hast halt einen Garbage Collector und du kannst da schon
deutlich klareren und und besser lesbare sachen schreiben als in rust ich sage nicht dass man in
rust gar nichts klar und lesbar schreiben kann aber manchmal kommt man in rust einfach nicht
dran vorbei was ekliges zu machen oder sachen zu machen die halt nicht nicht schön lesbar sind ich
hatte letztens ein beispiel hier im stream wo man halt mal wirklich sieht dass man bei rust nicht
drumherum kommt wie hieß das dann noch mal habe ich ein video geguckt erinnert sich da vielleicht
noch jemand da wollte ich das mal kurz zeigen naja ich weiß wieder wie das hieß das hieß rast feature
rast morse komplikated feature explained hieß das video so und da gab es am ende hier
ein code beispiel wie das aussehen muss in was das ist valid valid rast ist
so und so sah das am ende aus und das musstest du ihn was zu machen weil es sonst nicht funktioniert
so und da kann mir keiner sagen dass das schön klar lesbar ist das ist das ist das wo ich meine
du kommst manchmal bei rust in bestimmten cases nicht drumherum sachen umständlich und unleser
zu machen weil was braucht diese ganzen dinger damit es eben seine kompakt heimchecks machen
kann aber es kann mir keiner sagen chat dass das schön lesbar ist ich weiß jetzt kommt der
chat wieder und sagt doch doch max es ist ganz schön lesbar ich habe damit überhaupt keine
Probleme.
Im Vergleich
zu C++ ist es einfach weit einfach.
Ja gut. Ich meine
C++ als Vergleich zu nehmen ist ja immer so ein Ding.
C++ ist so ziemlich eines
der beschissensten
Programmiersprachen auf diesem Planeten, die es gibt.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind. Wir müssen irgendwann auch noch mal das hier
fertig gucken.
Was ist denn?
Das hier müssen wir auch noch irgendwann mal fertig gucken.
C++-Rant-Video.
Du kannst das lesen.
Dann erklär mal.
Was sieht man denn hier?
Also ich kann es mal versuchen zu erklären.
Rust.
was man hier sieht.
Und daran sieht man, dass Rust halt manchmal ein bisschen
Unterstützung braucht, damit es funktioniert.
Also,
hier wird ein Trade
gebaut.
Trade ist sowas wie ein Interface.
Also, in C Sharp oder Java
oder irgendwie Go,
wäre das ein Interface.
Also, das ist was, was andere
konkrete Typen dann implementieren.
Das ist ein Interface.
Da drinnen.
Also alle Typen, die dieses Interface implementieren, müssen auch die Funktion getUser implementieren.
Das hier sind RAS Lifetime Annotations.
Es gibt eine Lifetime Annotation Service, ID und Future.
Der erste Parameter, self, ist sowas wie this in Java oder C Sharp oder self in Python.
Das ist quasi so ein taktisch bisschen Zucker für Referenz auf das Objekt, was es dann implementiert, so Instanz.
Das hat eine Lifetime Annotation Service.
Und Service, das heißt, das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal eine Referenz.
So, ID ist ein String, Slice, sowas in der Richtung ist das.
Also eine Referenz hat die Lifetime Annotation ID.
jetzt überspringen wir diesen Kramer, da sage ich gleich was zu.
Was hier interessant ist, dass das hier eine Lifetime Annotation hat.
Warte mal.
Dass das, der Return Type, hat eine Lifetime Annotation von Future.
Das heißt, um das mal kurz zu machen, in Rust Logik ist ja,
Rust muss ja zur Compile-Zeit checken können, dass keine der Parameter, die du hier reingibst, wenn die quasi benutzt werden, um das Result zu erzeugen, dass die Dinger hier nicht gelöscht werden können, solange das, was zurückgegeben wird, noch gültig ist.
Also zum Beispiel, stellt euch mal vor, ihr übergebt als ersten Parameter einen String.
So, und als Return-Type habt ihr einen Array von Charaktern.
So, das ist jetzt...
Okay, ihr habt einen Array von Strings, okay?
So, und was die Funktion macht, ist, sie nimmt den String und baut dann irgendwie einen Array mit dem String drinnen und noch irgendwie Blub oder so zusammen.
Ist aber vollkommen egal.
jetzt ist das ding ja so dass der string im return in diesem was das was die funktion
return auch benutzt wird wenn jetzt dieser string gelöscht wird aber das was hier return
wird noch in benutzung ist dann hätte ja problem das ist das was wurde ich wurde dir in c++ auch
in fuß mit schießen kannst ja also wenn du das hier wenn das hier frien würde obwohl es hier
noch in diesem objekt was zurückgeben wird benutzt wird dann hätte besten fall crash ja so und
deswegen muss man was jetzt sagen das warst du hier returns das macht man nämlich auch in dem
web blog das warst du hier returns auf dem wo das passiert das muss mindestens genauso lange leben
wie der return type also sprich live station service muss so lange leben wie future live
annotation aldi muss so lange neben future das heißt was du nicht machen kannst ist irgendwas
hier in die funktion reinschieben was dann wieder gelöscht wird und dann wird noch länger verwendet
das heißt du kannst zum beispiel in static string static string kannst du rein schieben weil der
lebt für immer so das sind also lifetime annotation geschichte da musste ich den rast rum kümmern das
ist wichtig in rast weil der compiler zur kompilzeit checken können muss dass du keine
memory probleme kriegst das macht aber halt super hakelig an vielen stellen
das ist das ist das was diese definition hier sagt gut dass das hier ist auch
noch mal super alles aber für die für dieses beispiel ist das auch mal magic
aber das ist halt einfach nicht schön lesbar und du musst den rast so was
halt machen damit dass eben seine arbeit dass der compiler seine arbeit erledigen
kann
Deswegen bist du in Rust und kann mir keiner was erzählen, selbst wenn du richtig gut geübt bist, bist du nicht so produktiv wie jemand, der ähnlich gut geübt ist in der anderen Programmiersprache, wie zum Beispiel C Sharp oder meinetwegen JavaScript oder Python oder Go.
Da musst du solche Zeremonien halt nicht machen.
Ich...
Du kannst mittlerweile auch irgendwelche Annotations machen, dass das für dich implementiert wird oder so.
Aber der wollte in dem Video zeigen, was unter der Haube passiert.
Also wie man das ohne Annotations machen will, was Rust dann unter der Haube erzeugt.
Aber trotzdem kommst du in Rust halt manchmal nicht an solchen Dingern vorbei.
Die sind dafür auch nicht blazily fast.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Ja, ich sag ja, an Stellen, wo du wirklich maximale Performance brauchst und das Ganze so memory safe wie möglich, dann ist Rust gut.
Das ist aber für die meisten Programme nicht erforderlich.
Da ist es besser, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen langsamer und managt mit einem Garbage Collector dafür viel schneller zu programmieren und viel besser zu lesen.
wobei das besser lesen ja immer ein bisschen Geschmackssache ist,
aber du bist auf jeden Fall schneller in der Entwicklung.
Und da kann mir auch keiner erzählen, dass das nicht so ist.
Wenn du jemanden nimmst, der gut Rust kann,
der kriegt eine Aufgabe
und du nimmst jemanden, der, keine Ahnung, gut C-Sharp oder Go kann,
der kriegt die gleiche Aufgabe,
der in Go und C-Sharp, der ist einfach schneller fertig.
Und schneller fertig heißt ja im Endeffekt,
du kannst auch mehr Sachen implementieren in der gleichen Zeit.
Das ist dann einfach was umfangreicheres und was, was unterm Strich vielleicht sogar dann auch einfacher und besser benutzbar ist, weil da kommt es ja letztendlich drauf an, das darf man ja nicht vergessen. Es werden ja nicht Sachen programmiert des Programmierenswillens, also im Businessumfeld, ja, für uns hier hobbymäßig ist das was anderes, sondern weil den Kram irgendjemand benutzen soll.
und letztendlich interessiert kaum jemand in was das programmiert ist
guter code braucht keine dass da bin ich auch der meinung guter code braucht keine kommentare
das ist kein kapper ich meine das ernst ganz selten dass du das mal guter code kommentare
braucht guter code dokumentiert sich selbst was variablen die gut benannt sind was funktionen
die gut benannt sind objekte gut benannt sind bei manchen sachen macht es mit kommentare schon sinn
ja gerade wenn du irgendwelche sachen halt so machen musst weil du externe abhängigkeiten
hast so du musst zuerst das da rein schreiben danach muss das gemacht werden so weil das
dateiformat ist halt so vorsieht ja dann ist das sinnvolle kommentar darüber zu schreiben
Aber für die meisten sachen also die sind die sinnlosen kommentare ist hier set set gleich eins oder sowas
Wozu wenn da gleich 1 oder 0 oder so steht das sehe ich das muss dann nicht als kommentar darüber schreiben ja
Oder oder dann oder über den if so hier check
User ist valid ja gut wenn ich user valid oder irgendwie sowas das braucht man nicht
Ich glaube, Rust wird dieses Jahr
noch ein bisschen größer werden.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
bei Programmiersprachen ist es ja wie bei vielen Dingen so,
Es muss erstmal eine kritische Masse erreicht sein.
Und das geht erstmal so langsam, relativ linear so rauf.
Und irgendwann ist so die kritische Masse erreicht, dass es dann auch so anfängt ins Business rüber zu schwappen.
Und dann geht es steil hoch.
Viele Sprachen und Projekte erreichen diesen kritischen Punkt nie.
Aber Rust sagt mir mein Bauchgefühl
Dieses oder nächstes Jahr
Ist es bei Rust soweit
Wir werden da mehr von sehen
Ich finde man hat es auch letztes Jahr schon gemerkt
Das geht wirklich aufwärts
Das ist auch der Grund warum ich jetzt wieder ein bisschen mit Rust angefangen habe
Als erstens macht es Bock
Und es ist nicht verkehrt
Sachen zu kennen ist nie verkehrt
Achso hier Projekt vom Stream
von einem Zuschauer.
Wie eskält man im Twitch? Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das geht.
Vielleicht gar nicht.
Kann man Markdown schreiben im Twitch-Chat?
Nee, oder?
Glaube ich nicht.
Übrigens.
Warte mal.
Wir hatten es doch gerade
von Proxmox und VMware,
wo ich gesagt habe, also
ich würde jetzt bei irgendeiner kleinen
Werbeagentur oder sowas nicht unbedingt
denen da VMware-Zeug aufschwätzen.
Ich kann euch was
erzählen von der Arbeit.
Ähm,
VMware-Lizenzierung.
Die VMware wurde doch von Broadcom übernommen.
Hast du Miele-Geräte im Haus? Nee, hab ich nicht.
Wieso? Haben die irgendwelche Spyware oder so drauf?
Also, VMware wurde ja
von Broadcom übernommen.
Und Broadcom hat einfach mal die
Preise um das Zehnfache erhöht.
So, und jetzt war es so.
Wie sieht es mit Schnee draußen aus?
Warte mal, lass mich mal gucken.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ich habe heute noch gar nicht rausgeguckt.
Ein bisschen weiß ist es.
Ein bisschen weiß.
Und es ist minus 10 Grad.
Ich rede nicht von
VMware Workstation, ich rede von
VMware ESX und Wies 4 und
Wie heißt dieses andere Ding
Was früher Tanzu war jetzt
VMware Cloud
Foundation oder sowas
Ne, dafür
Reicht's nicht
Dafür reicht's nicht
Zum Schneestelzen
Ah, das ist sowas, wie ich für meine Wiesmann-Heizung hab
Ja, das ist genau sowas
Sowas hab ich für meine Wiesmann-Heizung auch
Mit so einem Optokoppler
Fuck
Nee, aber ich hab keinen Air Purifier
So, was wollte ich jetzt sagen, genau
So, und bei uns war es dann so
Wo wir jetzt gerade bei Vmware sind
Unsere, weiß ich nicht, wer das war
Irgendwelche Leute von uns auf der Arbeit
sind dann zu Broadcom gegangen und haben gesagt, das Zehnfache wollt ihr an Lizenzgebühren haben, das ist uns aber zu teuer.
Wir evaluieren jetzt mal Alternativen.
Obwohl die eigentlich wussten, dass es keine richtigen Alternativen gibt.
Ja, Vemba ist so tief Business Enterprise mäßig verzahnt, da kannst du nicht mit Proxmox oder irgendwie sowas um die Ecke kommen.
Wahrscheinlich benutzen wir auch wirklich sehr viele der advanced Features, die es da gar nicht gibt.
so und da hat vor allem er gesagt oder pro com gesagt ach wisst ihr was ihr seid ja so so guter
kunde und wir haben euch ja so gern ihr müsst nur das doppelte bezahlen jetzt als früher und da waren
beide seiten glücklich mit wir waren glücklich mit dass wir nur das doppelte bezahlen und pro
com war glücklich damit dass jetzt das doppelte bekommen also soweit sind wir schon soweit sind
wir schon bei der protokoll geschichte dass man glücklich darüber ist dass man nur das doppelte
bezahlen muss wie früher schnapper ja das ist ein rast programmiert also wenn ich wenn ich
miele geräte hätte dann würde ich das jetzt auch ausprobieren ich habe aber kein miele gerät
zumindest die waschmaschine ist auch keine miete also ich habe so was ähnliches ich habe wiesmann
opto link für meine heizung sowas hier guckt das ist so ein warum ist der sound jetzt wieder so
laut das triggert mich immer wenn das auch noch nicht los ja es gibt auch so ein opto koppler
für die heizung so was hier in der richtung ja und da kann ich auch über meine heizung
Infos abfragen. Da gibt es auch
ein GitHub-Projekt.
Das kenne ich noch gar nicht.
Das kenne ich noch nicht. Was ist das?
Ach ja.
Ah ne, das muss man selbst bauen.
Ja, gut. Ne, ich habe so ein fertiges paar USB.
Damit.
Damit lese ich meine Heizung aus.
Vor zwei Jahren. Nice. Top aktuell.
Wie sieht es eigentlich aktuell mit deiner Jogging-Fahrradkarriere aus?
Also, ich habe es Ende letzten Jahres ziemlich schleifen lassen.
Aber so seit...
Nicht ganz einem Monat, so seit drei Wochen oder so, renne ich wieder regelmäßig.
Heute bin ich wieder dran.
Gestern habe ich mal Pause gemacht.
Vorgestern 7,5 Kilometer.
Ich renne erstmal ohne Uhr, weil Trick 17.
also ohne Tracker
weil mich demotiviert
das immer so, wenn meine Uhr
anzeigt, Minus Performance
deswegen renne ich jetzt einfach erstmal so 2-3
Monate
bis ich wieder fit bin und dann ziehe ich meine Uhr
an und dann denkt die Uhr, Alter
der hat ja jetzt monatelang nicht gelaufen, der ist
richtig schlecht, dann misst die Uhr das
und sieht, boah der ist gar nicht so schlecht, dann sehe ich dann
grüne Pfeile Performance
Performance
Graf auf der Uhr geht dann nach oben.
Das ist beschisst, ich weiß es.
Das ist jetzt irgendwie
ausgetrickst, aber ich will,
dass meine Uhr anzeigt, dass
Performance da oben geht.
Das mache ich nicht mehr, das stresst mich,
habe ich gemerkt. Schlaf- und Herzfrequenz
tracken, das stresst mich.
Da denke ich immer, laufen, dass irgendwas ist.
Deswegen mache ich das nicht mehr.
Wenn überhaupt, ziehe ich die nur noch zum Joggen an.
Und Fahrrad bin ich jetzt so lang,
ist nicht gefahren. Ich bin ein paar Runden hier
auf meinem Hometrainer gefahren. Ich habe hier so einen
Wahoo
Kicker Core. So ein Ding habe ich ja.
Da stellt man dann sein
Fahrrad drauf. Genau sowas hier.
Da macht man quasi das
Hinterrad
raus.
Und macht dann sein
Antrieb hier
auf den Trainer.
Und da bin ich ein paar Mal gefahren.
Auf Swift.
Jetzt im Winter.
Aber sonst bin ich nicht viel gefahren.
Also ich weiß, wenn ich im Frühling...
Wenn ich im Frühling anfange, wieder ein bisschen Fahrrad zu fahren,
dann...
wird mir wieder der Arsch wehtun,
weil ich es nicht mehr gewohnt bin.
So.
Gibt es noch neue Updates?
Ich weiß, wir haben vor 20 Minuten Updates gemacht,
aber das ist Arch Linux.
keine updates moment mein system ist 40 minuten alt es gibt keine updates das ist aber nicht
bleeding edge genug max check thread mist aus bitte da habe ich gelesen da habe ich gelesen
auf reddit das angeblich ich sag angeblich ist auch nicht dass es so ist ja also das wohl der
entwickler recht shady sein muss habe ich auf reddit gelesen ich kann das weder bestätigen
noch dann doch bestätigen oder wie auch immer das nennt habe ich auf reddit gelesen und reddit ist
ja immer korrekt, wie wir wissen.
Keck B.
So.
Python 3.14, aha.
Sorgst du aktuell was?
Ja, ich bin gerade im dritten Akt von
Claire Obscure.
Das Problem, was ich mit dem Game
habe, ist, dass die Probleme
mit Steam und Windows Defender
haben. Ich hatte es jetzt, seit ich das
spiele, zweimal, dass es für mehrere
Tage nicht startbar war über Steam.
weil der Windows
Defender der Meinung war, das Spiel ist ein Virus.
Oder nicht richtig
signed oder sowas.
Ja, das Kampfsystem ist ziemlich
repetitiv. Wie nennt man das?
Wiederholt sich ziemlich.
Du machst immer mehr oder weniger die gleichen Dinger
und die gleichen Quicktime-Events.
Soll ich es über L4-6?
Nee, ich habe meinen Rechner extra neu installiert für Battlefield 6, aber noch Battlefield 6 nicht gespielt.
Call of Duty 4 Remastered, das ist doch schon ewig her, Call of Duty 4 Remastered.
Das ist doch von, sonst wann?
Ja, 2016.
Das habe ich mitbekommen, der ist mit seinem Porsche irgendwo dagegen gefahren
Das ist auch krass, ne?
Kommt es euch so vor, dass 2016 10 Jahre her ist?
Mir nicht
Das ist einer der Call of Duty
Erfinder
Und Apex Legends
Und der war auch an Battlefield 6
Beteiligt
Titanfall
Wenn es ist schade
Dass ihr Ain't Dice nicht hinbekommen
Wie sowas ist
Ich hab relativ viel Gutes gehört von Battlefield 6
Ich verfolge das aber auch nicht so weiter
Lass mich raten, lass mich raten, sag's nicht, sag's nicht
Lass mich raten, es gibt zu wenig Content
Und es kommt einfach nichts nach
Ah gut, die Spielerzahlen
Gehen immer runter
Ich mein, Battlefield 3
Hatte nach kurzer Zeit
Einen DLC mit 4 Maps und zig neuen Waffen
Und allem, und ich glaub Battlefield 6
Hat jetzt irgendwie eine halbe Map oder so
Gekriegt, oder eine Schnee-Version von der Map
Oder sowas
Okay.
Es ist noch nicht ganz ausgereift.
Ja, wer hätte das gedacht?
Sätge.
Ja, die Spiele haben aber auch mehr Content, muss man mal ehrlich sagen.
Bei Battlefield 3 haben die ja rausgehauen noch und öcher.
So.
GitHub-Trends haben wir geschaut, ne?
Ah ne, wir wollten ja gucken, was bei Rust so trendet.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Surreal-DB werde ich nicht verwenden.
Postgres-Beste oder SQLite.
Für mich gibt es nur SQLite oder Postgres.
Fertig.
Universal Android Deep Loader Next Generation.
Alter, wie lang...
Ich glaube, das ist legit der längste Projektname,
den ich hier auf github gesehen habe universal android die plotter next generation
reactive database vor app developer was nicht alles gibt turbo repo
trend ist es ein stelz editor
astgrep was sie allein von ford structural search land in writing written okay das
kann man zwar angucken telly jay kommt mir das habe ich schon ausprobiert dass ich kann
ich kriege immer anfälle wenn man terminal man maus captcha und sowas western beste
ja das hat es verdient zu trennen beste terminal hier starship auch gut habe ich
auch am einsatz der prompt hier ist starship leptos habe ich ausprobiert
mit trading stellt request hat die p libraries standardding vorrast alles
klar astkrepp was ist astkrepp was das ist ein relativ unglückliches beispiel
ich erkenne dem spiel ist ich kenne in dem screenshot nicht was es macht was
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Online Playground.
Okay.
Das ist mir zu high IQ.
Ich glaube, das brauche ich nicht.
Ja, das habe ich schon verstanden, aber ich habe den Output nicht mit dem Diff
Ich habe den Output mit dem Diff nicht gecheckt
Hast du mal GTA Online gespielt?
Ne
Oder es kann sein, dass ich es mal gestartet habe oder so
Weil ich habe ja GTA 5 gekauft
Aber ich habe GTA 5 nie richtig gespielt
Ich habe da keine Ahnung, 20 Minuten oder sowas
GTA, ich bin jemand, der hat den Hype um GTA nie verstanden
Ja, das kenn ich
Das kenn ich
Die 1 und 2 kenn ich noch
Aber selbst die haben mir nicht gefallen
Also insofern
Keine Ahnung
Was die Leute so geil an GTA finden
Hab ich aber nicht gespielt.
Du meinst so wie man das in Frankfurt halt macht?
Die Blutlache am Platz der Republik ist übrigens weg
Ich bin die Woche paar mal vorbeigelaufen
Ist nichts mehr davon zu sehen
Welche Konsole hast du gespielt?
Ich spiele nur noch PC
GTA 5
Ich spiele auch seit Jahren nur noch PC
Seit der Xbox 360
seitdem die Xbox 360 ausgelaufen ist, so langsam, aber sicher selbst schon während der Xbox 360,
bin ich eigentlich schon komplett wieder auf PC gelandet.
Ich habe übrigens gar keine aktuellen Konsolen.
Also die letzten Konsolen, die ich mir gekauft habe, waren eine PS4, die erste PS4,
und die erste Xbox, wie hieß das Ding damals? One? Xbox One?
Und seitdem habe ich mir keine Konsole mehr gekauft.
Und die einzige Konsole, die ich, also doch eine Switch habe ich mir noch gekauft,
Aber ich habe auch keine Switch 2.
Am Platz der Republik war immer so eine...
Also letztes Jahr, als ich da
vorbeigelaufen bin in Frankfurt, war immer eine Blutlache.
Wenn du...
Da ist so eine Wiener Feinbäckerei.
Am Platz der Republik.
Warte mal. Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich zeige es euch.
Man wird die Blutlache nicht wirklich sehen.
Äh.
Hier.
Wo ist die...
Hier ist die Bäckerei, oder?
Hier.
Hier ist, glaube ich, die Bäckerei.
Sieht man jetzt nicht. Wartet mal.
Äh.
Hier.
Hier ist die Bäckerei.
Kommt man da irgendwie rüber?
Und hier davor
war eine Blutlache.
Letztes Jahr.
Eher hier so.
Was passiert? Keine Ahnung.
Aber mittlerweile ist sie weg.
Ach, hier sieht man es noch besser.
Ja.
Hier so war die Blutlache.
Hier so.
Das hier sind die Hotspots.
Hier, Nidderstraße.
Hier musst du durchlaufen.
Da ist auch die Drogenausgabenstelle
Woher weißt du, dass es Blut war und nicht Barbecue?
Das weiß ich nicht
Aber es wäre ganz schön viel
und weit
ausgebreitete Barbecue-Soße gewesen
Also die Ecke hier hinten, die ist generell eklig.
So hier so.
Diese Ecke.
Hier ist auch irgendwo die Goethestraße.
Wo ist die Goethestraße?
Seht ihr irgendwo die Goethe Straße
Die ist hier aber auch
Goethe Straße
Da
Frankfurt Goethe Straße
Louis Vuitton Store
Zahl die Kollektion bar
Fick auf Sponsor
Haftbefehl wusste schon
Ich weiß gar nicht wo der Louis Vuitton Store hier ist
Aber irgendwo muss er
Wenn Haftbefehl das sagt irgendwo muss er hier sein
Guck die Rolex Boutique
Das hier ist für die Leute, die zu viel Geld haben
Weiß gar nicht, gibt es den überhaupt noch?
Da ist er, hier
All die Kollektionen, bar, fick auf Sponsor
Kann man das mit der Bahnhofstraße in Zürich vergleichen?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, da war ich ja nicht
Wenn es dann Rose Fahrradladen gibt, wäre nice.
Da hätte ich mir mal ein Fahrrad angucken können,
bevor ich es gekauft habe.
Umstieg eines C-Sharp-Desktops-Entwickler
von Windows auf CacheOS.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht,
der hat ganz viele Windows-Projekte.
Aber das gucken wir jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt gleich.
Aber ich bin mal gespannt,
was er dazu sagt.
So, was können wir uns jetzt angucken?
Was ist das? Tschüss Linux, warum ich leider
wieder zu Windows wechsle? Oh ja, da bin ich
mal gespannt. Ich sag ja, es ist nicht für jeden
was. Und gerade
wenn man denkt, dass Linux seine Windows-
Probleme löst, ist das auf Dauer auch nichts.
Man muss wirklich da rangehen mit.
das ist ein neues System
und ich muss mich da auch an das neue System
und neue Sachen gewöhnen.
Also wenn man das ein bisschen Power-User-mäßig
nutzen will, ja, wenn man da einfach nur
einen Browser aufmachen will, dann ist das egal.
Das ist letztendlich vollkommen egal, welches System.
Dann könnte es auch ein iPad sein.
Wie gesagt, ich habe meinem Vater ja auch so ein Mini-PC
mit Linux Mint vorbeigebracht, vor einer Weile
und das benutzt er,
der hat ja überhaupt keine Ahnung von, dass das kein Windows ist.
Der benutzt einen Browser und gut ist.
Das C++ Video haben wir nicht fertig, ne?
So, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch?
Tschüss Linux, warum ich leider wieder zu Windows wechsle?
Ich habe ja da auch mal ein Video drüber gemacht.
ich glaube die luft ist keine lösung wie habe ich das genannt
hier der der react der hat hier auf mein video reacted damals genau genau genau genau
ja ich habe mich darüber ausgelassen dass das nicht das die looks nicht seine nicht
die windows probleme der leute löst sondern das eigene system ist aber auch da so rangehen
muss. Aber wenn man sich drauf einlässt
und, sagen wir mal, nicht irgendwelche
wirklich komplette K.O.
Kriterien hat,
wie Spiele mit Anti-Cheat oder sowas,
kann man damit auch glücklich werden.
Er macht auch Twitch.
Naja.
Dann hören wir uns das doch mal an.
Geht noch fünf Minuten, warum er wieder von
Linux zu Windows ist.
Schauen wir doch mal.
... saß ich hier und hab euch erzählt, dass ich weg von Windows will.
Das hört sich ja schon mal sehr motiviert an.
Ich hab CacheOS installiert, ich hab Benchmarks in mehreren Spielen gemacht
und ich war wirklich, wirklich überzeugt davon, dass ich nicht mehr zu Windows zurückkehren will.
Tja, das hat aber wohl leider nicht so gut geklappt.
Ich muss heute ehrlich zu euch sein.
Das Experiment ist für mich gescheitert.
Auf diesem Rechner läuft meistens wieder Windows.
Und ich geh immer nur in Linux, um neue Videos zu machen oder neue Benchmarks aufzunehmen.
Also ich benutze Linux eigentlich nicht, um dort zu arbeiten.
Und in diesem Video erkläre ich euch, warum es keine Entscheidung gegen Linux war,
sondern eine Entscheidung für meine Nerven und für meine Zeit.
Das versteht mich nicht falsch. Die ersten zwei Wochen waren magisch.
Linux Gaming fühlt sich wahnsinnig an.
Das habe ich von vielen Leuten schon gehört, dass das viel besser ist, als man denkt mit Spielen unter Linux.
Dass der Großteil einfach funktioniert.
Nichtsdestotrotz, mit Anti-Cheat gibt es immer noch
Riesenprobleme, das tut halt einfach gar nichts
Das tut gar nicht, also
geht nicht
Und bei manchen Sachen brauchst du halt immer noch Guides
Weil du irgendwelche Sachen tweaken musst
Aber es muss wohl deutlich besser
Sein, als man so erwartet
Können wir in zweifacher Geschwindigkeit schauen?
Warte mal
Viele Titel liefen sogar besser als unter Windows.
Ihr konntet in meinem Arc Raiders Video sehen, dass die Performance gut war.
Und auch in Path of Exile, dass das Spiel brutal weich lief.
CacheOS ist ein fantastisches System.
Es sieht gut aus, es ist schnell, es ist performant.
So ist besser, oder?
Vor allem gehört es einem selber ganz alleine und nicht einem Riesenkonzern.
Eigentlich lief alles.
Die Spiele starteten, Proton hat funktioniert.
Ich dachte wirklich, das ist es.
Ich kann jetzt zu Linux wechseln.
Aber dann kam der Alltag.
Und der Alltag, der ist mein Endgegner.
Das erste Problem ist meine Nvidia-Karte.
Das ist tatsächlich ein Problem.
Nvidia unter Linux, das ist ja
Ist auch wieder so eines der Dinger, ja
Unter Linux ist das immer noch eine Hassliebe
Ja, es läuft, aber es läuft nicht perfekt
Unter Linux hatte ich unter Wayland immer wieder kleine Glitches
Und Abstürze
Nvidia und Wayland, ja
Es sind Spiele, sobald ich raus tappe
Ich konnte zum Beispiel auch nicht meinen zweiten Bildschirm
Also generell, Wayland ist ein Problem
Bei einigen Sachen und Nvidia ist recht
44 Hertz stellen
Denn sobald ich das getan habe, habe ich komische Schlieren auf dem Bildschirm gehabt
Musste diesen auf 120 Hertz draußen
Und versteht mich nicht falsch, allgemein kann man so spielen.
Ist zwar nichts, was irgendwas unspielbar gemacht hat,
aber es waren immer wieder viele kleine Sachen, viele kleine Frickeleien,
um irgendwelche Probleme zu beheben.
Ob es meine Razormaus ist, für die es nicht den perfekten Treiber gibt.
Ob es die Elgato-Produkte sind, die ich benutze, weil sie einfach funktionieren
und hier mit verschiedensten Workarounds arbeiten muss.
Oder ob es wie ein Spiel wie WoW ist, welches man einfach nur schnell installieren will,
man sich aber erstmal im Internet einen Guide raussuchen muss.
Das hast du halt an vielen Stellen,
dass du ein paar Kleinigkeiten dann nicht weiterkommst
und erst mal ins Arch-Wiki oder so gucken musst.
Ist halt so. Letztendlich ist das das, was ich meine.
Man muss sich halt da schon wirklich auf Linux einlassen
und auch nicht damit rangehen,
es ist jetzt einfach wie Windows
und es geht auch alles wie unter Windows,
nur dass es nicht die Sachen hat,
die mich abfacken unter Windows.
Das ist halt so. Nicht.
Und weil ich keinen perfekten Guide gefunden habe,
habe ich einfach selber einen erstellt.
Guckt einfach oben an der Infokarte nach.
Und ich bin ehrlich, ich will abends einfach nur mal zocken.
Und wenn ich dann jedes Mal in ein Forum gucken muss,
weil ich irgendeinen Fehler wieder habe, den ich nicht so schnell beheben kann,
dann nervt das.
Und irgendwann fragt man sich, ist Windows wirklich so schlimm,
dass ich dadurch jetzt so viel Freizeit opfere?
Der eigentliche Killer war bei meiner Arbeit.
Ich brauche Programme, die unter Linux einfach nicht laufen.
Oder nur mit extrem viel Gefricke.
Also zum Beispiel Adobe Premiere Pro
oder die ganzen Office-Tools, die mich eh wieder zu Microsoft führen.
Ja, gut.
Da muss ich sagen, mit Office habe ich das Problem nicht.
Ich bin ja kein großer Office-Benutzer, das wisst ihr ja.
Aber ich habe trotzdem ein Office-Abo, das liegt aber hauptsächlich an der 1TB, wie heißt das Ding von Microsoft hier, der Shit, den ich eigentlich aninstallt habe, der aber wieder da ist, OneDrive, Speicherplatz, aber ich verwende doch manchmal Office-Programme und die verwende ich im Browser.
Man muss sagen, Office läuft im Browser ganz gut.
Ja, du hast so ein paar Sachen und irgendwelche Native Add-ons und so.
Aber ganz ehrlich, 99% von dem, was ich in Office mache,
mir fällt jetzt übrigens nichts ein, was die verbleibenden 1% sind,
kann ich im Browser machen.
Ich verwende manchmal PowerPoint.
Ach, sorry, Leute, es ist ja nicht mehr Office.
Wobei das ja auch nicht richtig stimmt.
Es ist ja jetzt Microsoft 365 Co-Pilot App oder sowas.
Was nicht richtig stimmt, sie haben ja dann zurückgerudert und nochmal klargestellt,
nein, nein, ist ja gar nicht so, aber die Nachricht war halt echt dämlich wieder.
Ich habe doch das hier
Ich habe doch hier gepostet auf Twitter
Also Microsoft hat
Folgendes geschrieben hier
Microsoft 365
In Klammern Office
App is now called
The Microsoft 365
Co-Pilot App
Across Web, Office.com
Microsoft 365, Mobile and Windows.
New Upname, Icon, Reflections,
Integrations, Copylefts.
Angeblich ist es jetzt so,
dass Office,
also Office wurde ja schon umbenannt in Microsoft
365 vor zwei Jahren oder so.
Keine Sau
nennt
Office Microsoft 365.
Guck mal, man muss sich das mal
auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Das
Renaming war so erfolgreich,
dass sie noch in klammern schreiben müssen office weil keine sau weiß was
markt auf 365 ist aber microsoft und benahmung habe ich mir schon oft darüber
ausgelassen
aber es ist ja anscheinend so dass microsoft 365 weiterhin markt auf 365
bleibt und nur irgendwie eine app umbenannt wurde aber ich finde es halt
total hängen geblieben also man kann das man kann das doch
wirklich so lesen oder dass microsoft 365 office now called copilot so also
das ist maximal dämlich geschrieben da hat auch einer hier das ganze
korrigiert in den commons
ach so da ich etwas witzig fand ich hätte geschrieben was ich schlechter
Microsoft-Namensgebung oder C++-Namensgebung
Syntax-Design.
Und bei der Gelegenheit ist mir aufgefallen,
dass ein
Microsoft-Mitarbeiter sogar
jahrelang Vorsitzender des
C++-Gremiums war. Wusstet ihr das?
Da wundert
ich nichts mehr.
So, und der hier hat
geschrieben, guck mal, das wurde überhaupt
nicht umbenannt. Und
da muss man ehrlich sagen, also ja,
selbst wenn das nicht umbenannt wurde,
ist das hier halt maximal
dumm geschrieben, weil es liest sich halt
wirklich so, als würde das schon wieder umbenannt.
Das ist ein Twitter-Frontend, ja.
Ein Twitter-Frontend, wo man sich nicht einloggen muss.
Ja.
Okay. Gucken wir mal.
Wie auch in den Videos erwähnt, ein Duel,
System eingerichtet. Ja, Dualboot ist
zum Scheitern verurteilt, meiner Meinung nach.
Man ist einfach zu faul.
Also Dualboot klappt nicht. Das ist übrigens auch
der Grund, warum ich mein Linux hier hab und mein Windows
hier hab. Also Windows da, Linux da.
Weil Dualboot kannst du knicken.
Dualboot ist mal viel zu faul.
Windows zum Arbeiten. Und ich wollte immer mehr
zu Linux rüberziehen. Klingt in der Theorie super.
In der Praxis ist es der Tod für Linux.
Folgendes Szenario. Ich arbeite bis abends.
Ich mach irgendwelche Sachen am PC. Und dann
denke ich mir, soll ich jetzt nochmal eben eine Runde
zocken und was mache ich dann? Dann öffne
ich einfach Steam und zock los. Dann fahre ich
nicht wieder den PC runter. Ja, genau.
Versuch da das. Da ist man viel zu
faul für, das kann ich nachvollziehen.
Zu starten, wenn ich es da schon installiert habe.
Ich bin halt faul, ich gehe den Weg des geringsten
Widerstands und der ist nun mal in Windows einfach
los zu zocken. Ich habe die Linux-Partition dann immer
nur noch aus Interesse gestartet und wollte einfach
gucken, was ich dort Neues lernen kann.
Und ich möchte jetzt nicht extra suchen, was
Der könnte das übrigens super in der VM machen.
Für den wäre das auch ein gutes Setup,
Windows als Hauptsystem, Linux in der VM.
Da kannst du Linux lernen, kannst auch tagtäglich
drin arbeiten, aber hast nicht
diese Dual-Boot-Hürde
und kannst trotzdem dein Kram unter
Windows machen, der halt nur unter Windows gescheit geht.
Kann ich euch jetzt unbedingt zeigen,
was bringe ich mir noch bei, nur damit ich ein neues Video
habe mit Linux. Ich habe einfach gemerkt, dass ich
kein Linux-YouTuber bin. Ich habe auch bei anderen
Linux-YouTubern geguckt und die
sind da mit ganz viel Herzblut bei.
Und ein paar Mythen aufzuklären und das finde ich
auch immer noch gut. Solche Videos werden immer
noch kommen, aber es wird jetzt nicht mehr,
also dieser Kanal wird sich jetzt nicht hauptsächlich um Linux
drehen. Und ich möchte, dass mein Betriebssystem...
Ja gut, dann haben wir das eigentlich,
das ist schon abgehakt. Ja, kann ich
nachvollziehen. Valid
Reason so.
So, was haben wir
denn hier sonst noch so? Informatik.
Job-Einstieg als Software-Entwickler
bei SAP. MonkaS.
Wo wir gerade bei nervigen
Lizenzbedingungen sind. Da kommt
ja die, die Broadcom noch toppen.
Okay, Oracle vielleicht noch.
Oracle ist auch so ein Ding.
Broadcom, Oracle,
SAP, Alter, Leute.
Haben wir das schon geschaut?
Wirklich?
Ich weiß nicht,
wenn man jetzt sie eingibt.
Haben wir das schon geschaut?
Ich glaube nicht.
Was man mit Linux lernt?
Ja, zum Beispiel Linux.
Am besten lernt man das mit Benutzen.
Aber wenn du da prinzipiell eh kein Interesse dran hast, dann lass es bleiben.
Zwingt einen ja keiner.
Also Konsole ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt, wenn man mit Linux anfängt.
Das Beste, um zu lernen ist, einfach zu versuchen, tägliche Arbeit unter Linux zu erledigen.
Dann wird man immer über irgendwelche Hürden stolpern.
und dann muss man halt gucken, wie man die löst.
Ja, also wenn du jetzt beispielsweise viel,
was weiß ich, irgendwelche Python-Skripts machst oder sonst was,
machst du es halt nicht unter Windows, sondern unter Linux.
Was du halt so daily schreibst.
Nee, WSL finde ich nicht so schön.
Ich finde es besser, wenn man komplettes Linux,
wenn man komplettes Linux-System hat, auch mit Frontend und allem.
WSL ist unter der Haube, ist eine Hyper-V VM.
Also ich finde das so mit VM und mit Linux-UI und so auch besser.
Was meinst du hier? Hä?
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Also wir haben es letztens ausprobiert.
Mein Drucker, das war easy.
Wir haben hier CacheOS installiert, hier CacheOS, habe ich Drucker hinzugefügt, zweimal auf weiter gedrückt und es hat funktioniert.
Ja, wenn dich das interessiert, gut, ich meine Browser aufmachen und ChatGPT, das ist jetzt unter Windows und Linux nicht so viel Unterschied.
Aber was du zum Beispiel machen kannst, wenn du gerne programmierst, ich benutze OpenCode.
Ich benutze OpenCode.
als Terminal-AI-Client.
Finde ich ganz praktisch, ja.
Kann man dann fragen hier, keine Ahnung.
Ich brauche ein
minimales Rust-Beispiel.
So, irgendwie sowas.
Also kannst du dann, anstatt im Browser, kannst du OpenCode
verwenden. Schön, dass OpenCode ist. OpenCode hat halt damit, weil es nicht im Browser ist,
auch Zugriff auf deine Dateien.
Ich zeig dir das mal. Wir gehen jetzt mal hier in Repos.
Gehen wir hier rein. Starten OpenCode.
Dann sagen wir okay.
OpenCode. Ich hab da sogar
ein Makro schon für.
Explain Project.
Jetzt guckt er nach.
In dem Projekt.
in dem Folder, in der Dateistruktur.
Was das ist?
Das ist übrigens GLM 4.7 in der Free-Version.
Deswegen ist das auch ein bisschen langsam.
Und aktuell hängt es.
Am Wochenende ist halt...
Das braucht aber echt lang jetzt.
Vielleicht ist GLM 4.7 gerade überlastet.
Keine Ahnung.
Scheint so.
Machen wir nochmal.
Okay.
Jetzt hat er es gecheckt.
Dann sucht er mal ein Projekt.
Und gibt mir dann eine ordentliche Übersicht.
Also GLM 4.7 ist gerade krass überlastet, so wie es aussieht.
Tja, manchmal macht es halt auch Sinn, für was zu bezahlen, wenn man es benutzen will.
Was haben wir hier sonst noch? The Best.
Gucken wir nochmal, was der hier hat. Job-Einstieg als Softwareentwickler bei SAP.
Also GLM 4.7 ist richtig hart überlastet gerade.
Probieren wir nochmal was anderes. Probieren wir nochmal das andere Model.
Ups, jetzt habe ich es interrupted. Ich kack nur.
Probieren wir doch mal Minimax M 2.1.
Gucken, ob das schneller ist.
Hä? Das ist immer noch 4.7?
3?
Ne, jetzt ist es das Richtige.
Ja, die Free Models sind gerade echt, am Wochenende sind die immer ziemlich rate limited.
So, guck, und jetzt kriegst du hier die Erklärung.
Project Purpose, Domain Registration, Data Lookup Tool, bla bla bla.
Domain Quering, kriegst du sogar eine Übersicht gemalt, die ein bisschen irgendwie komisch formatiert ist.
was hier passiert wie das projekt aufgebaut ist eigentlich ganz nice
also opencode finde ich in der commandline für AI-Usage echt nice
so gucken wir uns doch mal an was er hier treibt job einstieg als
softwareentwickler bei sap muss man erst mal lernen leise lizenzen
zu wobei softwareentwickler verkaufen keine lizenzen
In was ist denn eigentlich SAP selber programmiert?
Ich kenne von SAP.
Da gibt es, wie heißt das?
ABAP oder so, ne?
SAP, diese SAP Language.
Das ist abab.
ABAP SAP.
Aber in was ist denn das SAP Zeug selbst programmiert?
Bestimmt Java oder sowas.
Dritte Teil auf der PS2, ne.
Also Rust-Test habe ich noch nie benutzt, keine Ahnung.
So, schauen wir mal.
Hello everybody and welcome to this session.
Was gar nicht passieren darf, ist, dass mir eben ein Fehler unterläuft.
Gerade bin ich maximal nervös.
So ist das.
Immer Fehler.
Das ist das, was ich im Stream auch predige.
Das kann alles so einfach sein, wenn man nie Fehler macht.
Ja, man spart sich Dokumentation, Tests.
Man muss einfach immer first try alles richtig machen ohne Fehler.
Das Video hatten wir schon, wirklich?
Okay, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Mein Hirn ist gerade am Aussetzen.
Stimmt.
Ja, das kennen wir schon.
Ja, ja, ja, das kennen wir schon.
Okay, nee, dann, wenn wir das schon geguckt haben, gucken wir das nicht nochmal.
Oder nochmal gucken, ich kann mich nämlich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Keine Ahnung, was die da da haben.
Software-Ingenieur bei BMW.
Das können wir uns angucken.
Da gucken wir uns den an.
Okay, ist so laut. Toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss.
Das große Ziel meines Programms ist es, quasi dem Fahrzeug beizubringen, wie ein Mensch sich in der...
Das hatten wir auch schon? Alter!
Ja, dann halt nicht, ja?
Dann halt nicht, dann gucken wir uns das Beste von der CES 2026 an.
YouTube leer geschaut?
Nee, das liegt daran,
dass ich ja hier nicht eingeloggt
bin.
Und
als ich mein Rechner neu
aufgesetzt hab, ist irgendwie die YouTube-History
weg gewesen. Und jetzt muss der
neu lernen, was ich mir angucken will.
Das interessiert mich
privat, das Video. Ich glaube nicht, dass euch das
interessiert. Weil ob ich mir so
Ugreen Nass kaufen soll.
In Zukunft hab ich mir auch schon überlegt.
Aber nicht für Ugreen, sondern zum
Proxmox installieren.
CR ist immer die größte
Quatschveranstaltung, ja. Das stimmt.
Aber manchmal sind trotzdem ein paar ganz interessante
Sachen dabei.
Kannst du nicht ein Account für Streaming
machen? Theoretisch wäre das nicht
unsinnig, ja.
Das haben wir auch schon geguckt.
Nee, das ist was anderes.
Das ist was anderes.
Und die findet gerade in Las Vegas statt.
Lego mit Soundeffekten, Hui!
Computer in der Tastatur, Hui!
Roboter, die Waschmaschinen ausräumen, Hui!
Das ist einfach nur Gimmick für die, für diese Messe.
Wirklich Anwendungszweck gibt es ja da.
Hui!
Wir haben die spannendsten Sachen rausgesucht und das, indem wir einfach geguckt haben,
was bei uns ganz persönlich den größten haben will.
Reflex ausgelöst hat.
Ja gut, oder was wir am peinlichsten fanden. Bleibt dran.
Liebe Hackerin.
Hui.
Liebe Internet-Surfer.
Herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Wir hören immer wieder, dass viele von euch weg wollen von den ganzen Cloud-Anbietern in den USA.
Und da kommt unser Sponsor ins Spiel.
Das ist nämlich Internext aus Valencia in Spanien.
Spanien. Die bieten einen Open Source
Cloud Speicher Dienst an, der den Fokus auf
Datenschutz und Sicherheit legt. Internext
verspricht Zero Knowledge Verschlüsselung und
Post Quanten Kryptografie. Die
Komponenten liegen hier alle auf GitHub. Ihr könnt
also genau nachschauen, was da so passiert.
Nee, Serious Max, such ich
auch, auch nicht gefunden.
Hui heißt
auf Russisch Schwanz. Ernsthaft?
Dann kenn ich das jetzt schon in
mehreren Sprachen. Ich weiß, dass es
Jarak heißt, das auf Türkisch, glaube ich.
Schwanz.
Hui, heißt doch frustrig, so so.
Yep, cock.
Besonders ist, ihr müsst kein Abo abschließen,
sondern Internext bietet auf Wunsch auch einen Einmalkauf an,
also quasi ein lebenslanges Abo.
Außerdem gibt's VPN, Antivirensoftware und Cleaner obendrauf.
Die Clients gibt's für Windows, Mac und...
Wisst ihr, was ich immer geil finde?
Wenn's da um Privacy und bla bla geht und dann höre ich Cloud-Dienst.
ist nicht jetzt mal objektiv gesehen chat ich weiß nicht wie ihr das seht ja würde mich interessieren
ist nicht daten in die cloud hochladen das exakte gegenteil von privacy dass das ist kein vpn dienst
also bald ich war es in die cloud hochladen ist es bei einem anderen anbieter wo ich keine ahnung
habe was da eigentlich passiert gut wenn du sie verschlüsselt das ist was aber selbst da also
sobald du die daten erst mal raus gegeben hast haben ja andere leute prinzipiell zugriff drauf
und weißt du nicht ob das ist ja das was immer mit post quanten kryptographie und so schreiben
wollen was man ja nicht weiß ist wenn du jetzt heute was verschlüsselt das hoch lädt ob das in
zehn jahren immer noch so gut verschlüsselt ist vielleicht ist ja die verschlüsselung
ist eingeknackt also ich bin ich bin der meinung wenn man die daten erst gar nicht
aus der hand gibt kann man auch keine probleme bekommen also daten nicht
teilen ist besser als datenschutz so in dem sinn oder privacy
wenn überhaupt würde ich kleinzeitig verschlüsseln ja selbst und selbst dann
selbst wenn der anbieter sagt wir machen das schon ich würde immer selbst verschlüsseln
so eng fs oder irgendwie sowas auf datei ebene und dann in die cloud zünden erst dass die cloud
software nur verschlüsselte daten sieht
nicht rausgehen ist eh beste
nee aber du kannst das minimieren und es ist ja kein alles oder nichts
aber je weniger du raus gibst dir weniger kann verloren gehen also mit
verloren gehen meine ich irgendwo geleakt werden oder irgendwie abgegriffen werden oder sonst was
soll wir gucken das video ist das mal
will ich auch für linux mit dem code ct 3003 gibt es 87 prozent rabatt und das ist deutlich
mehr als der standard rabatt auf der website link ist in der beschreibung erbung ende ja den in
offiziellen ct 3003 halbpokal bekommt auf jeden fall lego die ein lego stein vorgestellt haben
ja der sieht aus wie der ikonische vier mal zwei lego stand ein smarter lego steine klemm baustein
oder ein aber drin ist high tech und lego feuert wirklich pr mäßig aus allen horn also seit über
zehn jahren sei das ding in der entwicklung 25 patente seien angemeldet worden alles nur für
die neue smart play serie von lego beziehungsweise für diesen ein lego stein ja und da drin stecken
ein akku mehrere rgb led sound chip lautsprecher mikrofon und das eigens entwickelte neighbor
position measurement system das pm ja das arbeitet mit kupferspulen also nahfeldfunk und kann damit
spezielle Lego Minifiguren und die neuen Smart Tag Lego Teile im Raum lokalisieren. Also relativ zum
Smart Brick. Der Smart Brick, das ist quasi die Schaltzentrale, aber damit das ganze Spaß macht,
braucht man nicht nur den Smart Brick, sondern braucht man auch diese zwei weiteren Lego Elemente,
die die Smart Tags und oder so eine Minifigur mit Spule drin. Kleines Beispiel, ihr baut so
einen Hubschrauber, in dem so ein 4x2 Smartbrick drinsteckt und dann passiert erstmal noch gar
nichts. Aber sobald ihr dann das entsprechend vorbereitete Smarttag mit einbaut, dann weiß
der Smartbrick, aha, ich bin ein Hubschrauber, also mache ich Hubschraubergeräusche und blinkt
vielleicht so ein bisschen. Na ja, das jetzt als krasse Sache zu verkaufen. Hält man den
Hubschrauber auf den Kopf, merkt der Smartbrick das und kann entsprechende, ich stürze gleich ab,
Geräusche machen und ja, was weiß ich, rot leuchten. Ja und kommt man dann auch noch so einer Minifigur nahe, könnte dann sowas ertönen wie, oh nein, bitte mir nicht auf den Kopf fliegen. Aber es kommt nicht aus der Minifigur, sondern aus dem Smartbrick-Lautsprecher, weil SmartTag und Minifig, die arbeiten passiv.
Was?
Habt ihr das auch gerade verstanden?
haben also nur eine Spule drin und haben keinen Akku und keinen Lautsprecher.
Also die ganze aktive Technik steckt im Smartbrick.
Was ich wirklich gut finde daran, man muss den Kram nicht mit einer Smartphone-App oder so koppeln,
sondern das soll alles autark, out of the box funktionieren.
Man kann die Smartbricks über Bluetooth updaten, also das muss man ja können.
Wenn man einen Smartbrick von 2026 hat und dann den mit einem Set von 2028.
2028 früher haben die kinder mit dem hubschrauber gespielt haben dabei lange macht oder irgendwas
haben selbst geräusche gemacht ich benutzen will dann kann der alte smart brick das ja gar nicht
wissen also muss er geupdatet werden der brick muss ja irgendwie die sound samples und solche
sachen her bekommen übrigens sagt lego dass man zurzeit noch nicht selber irgendwelche sachen
programmieren kann der irgendwelche sprach samples einsprechen lego schließt aber nicht aus dass sie
das in Zukunft machen wollen.
Achso, ja klar. Und den Smartbrick, den muss man
natürlich laden. Das geht aber natürlich
auch induktiv. Das heißt, da muss man kein
Kabel reinstecken, sondern man hat dann so
eine kleine Ladestation und stellt die
Smartbricks da drauf oder den Smartbricks.
Erstmal Firmware-Update machen.
Lego-Steine erstmal Firmware-Update.
Mich wundert heute aber eh nichts mehr mit
Firmware-Update. Ich musste sogar meine
Fahrradpedale Firmware-Update letztens.
Dass das auch
noch klappen soll, wenn der
jahrelang irgendwo rum gelegen hat das ist ja sonst oft ein problem mit akkus also tiefentladung und
so also daran ist gedacht lego sagt auch dass das eingebaute mikrofon nicht irgendwie zum abhören
missbraucht werden kann sondern nur dazu dient mit klopfen oder so irgendwelche funktionen auszulösen
naja also wollen wir mal abwarten was der ccc so macht wenn er das teil in die füße kommt ja
apropos in die finger bekommen das geht am ersten märz dann sollen die ersten sets in den handel
kommen. Man kann die ab dem 9. Januar
auch sogar vorbestellen, die Dinger.
Achso, welche Dinger überhaupt? Ja, die ersten
Sets, die da kommen mit dieser Smartplay-Technik,
das sind alle Star Wars-Sets.
Das preisgünstigste ist
Darth Vader's TIE Fighter.
Der kostet 69,99 Euro.
Da sind 473 Teile drin.
Davon ein Smartbrick und eine
Smartplay-Kompatibel.
Da hat der Held der Steine sicherlich was dran auszusetzen.
Ne Minifigur.
Also ich muss sagen, von den Sachen,
die ich weiß und die ich gesehen habe, hätte ich
direkt Lust damit zu spielen, aber 70 Euro sind natürlich auch schon heftig und ich muss sagen,
so richtig kann ich es mir noch nicht vorstellen, wie toll das ist oder ob das einfach nur so ein
Effekt ist, den man nach zehn Sekunden schon durch hat, muss ich mir wirklich angucken, will ich mir
auch angucken, testen wir vielleicht sogar hier bei 3003, mal sehen. Ja, aber richtige Computer-
technik gab es natürlich auch auf der CES. Sehr interessant fanden wir das HP Elite Board G1A.
Diese kleine Tastatur hier sieht auf den ersten Blick super unspannend aus, ist sie aber nicht,
denn da steckt ein kompletter PC drin. Ein mobiler x86 Rechner, den man per USB-C an
Bildschirme anschließen kann. Laut HP soll sich der Tastatur-PC besonders für Arbeitnehmer mit
wechselnden Arbeitsplätzen eignen. An denen muss dann halt nur ein Bildschirm und eine Maus stehen.
Das Ding zu transportieren sollte auch echt easy sein, weil mit 726 Gramm ist die Tastatur einfach
nur ein bisschen schwerer als ein Steam Deck. Drinnen steckt ein Ryzen AI 300 Prozessor mit
Nicht übel.
Bis zu 8 Kern, maximal 2 TB SSD-Speicher und bis zu 64 GB RAM.
Falls euch das Prinzip irgendwie bekannt...
Okay, also wird's teuer.
Ja, sowas gibt's schon mit Raspis.
Zum Beispiel hier mit dem Raspi 400 oder auch neuerdings mit dem Raspi 500.
Aber die Tastatur wirkt besser.
Die aber deutlich weniger Leistung haben als das Teil jetzt von HP.
Was es denn kosten soll, hat HP bisher noch nicht gesagt.
Nur, dass es wohl im März rauskommen soll.
Ja, und dann gab's auch...
Also käme für mich schon mal nicht in Frage, weil mir wahrscheinlich die Tastatur überhaupt nicht gefällt.
Auch noch neue Prozessoren.
Zum Beispiel von Intel, die endlich den Panther aus dem Sack gelassen haben.
Ja, die Panther Lake Architektur haben die released, die offiziell Core Ultra 300 heißt.
Ist für Notebooks und, Achtung, für Gaming Handhelds gedacht.
Und da hat Intel tatsächlich schon Acer, MSI und GPD genannt,
die allesamt solche tragbaren Spielkonsolen rausbringen wollen.
Warum? Ja, weil das ist nämlich das Besondere an den Panther Lake Chips,
das ist die integrierte B390 Grafikeinheit.
Die ist ziemlich schnell, laut Intel bis zu 77% schneller als der eigene Luna Lake Vorgänger
und bis zu 73% schneller als ein AMD Ryzen AI9 HX370 mit Radeon 890M.
Dafür haben...
Wird wahrscheinlich auch ganz gut zu der Linux laufen.
Ah, wen juckt's, was Intel da treibt?
Also Intel sagt zum Beispiel, dass das Lenovo IdeaPad mit dem neuen Topmodell Core Ultra X9 388H beim Net...
Die Produktnamen sind immer wieder geil, ne?
Streaming sage und schreibe 27 Stunden durchhält.
Und das ist schon ein ziemlich guter Wert.
Die CES war immer schon voller Roboter.
Dieses Jahr aber wirklich besonders krass.
Und ja klar, Roboter.
Gab es da nicht auch diesen Roboter, der jetzt so ein Salto machen konnte?
Irgendwas habe ich letztens in einem Video gesehen.
Roboter sind cool und manchmal süß und machen sich auch auf so einer Keynote-Bühne gut.
Aber es ist auch klar, dass das in den meisten Fällen eben Dekoration ist.
oder irgendwelche Visionen und keine wirklichen Produkte.
So leider auch Cloyd von LG, den man auf der CS sehen konnte, wie er kocht und Wäsche faltet.
Aber wenn ihr euch so Hoffnungen macht wie ich, müsst ihr nicht, weil das dauert noch,
wenn das Ding denn überhaupt so kommt, wie es da zu sehen war.
Der LG-Konkurrent Samsung, der hängt dann schon am Teppich fest.
... hat 2020 ja den Kugelroboter Bollief gezeigt, auch auf der CES, und den gibt's halt bis heute nicht.
Also sechs Jahre später.
Ein bisschen konkreter ist der Switchbot Onero H1, der angeblich noch in diesem Jahr lieferbar sein soll, für unter 10.000 Euro.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich spreche aus langjähriger CES-Erfahrung, man darf skeptisch sein.
Auch wenn...
Ey, wie sieht das Ding blöd aus?
Wenn der Onero H1 nicht auf zwei Beinen läuft, sondern quasi nur auf dem Staubsaugerroboter montiert ist,
hm, weiß ich nicht.
Deutlich aufregender und leider auch deutlich, deutlich, deutlich teurer ist der Atlas von Boston Dynamics,
der nach vielen Jahren jetzt wirklich in Serie geht.
Also nicht als Haushaltsroboter, sondern zum Beispiel in einem US-amerikanischen Hyundai-Werk, wo das Ding Dachgepäckträger sortiert. 50 Kilo.
Stimmt, das sieht aus wie so ein Ventilator, das stimmt.
Soll so ein Atlas tragen können und ja, Sachen beherrschen, die Menschen definitiv nicht können.
Also was man auf jeden Fall verzeichnen kann, ist, dass der KI-Boom auch wirklich große Fortschritte im Machine Learning hervorgebracht hat
und dass das tatsächlich gerade die ganze Roboterbranche ziemlich nach vorne bringt.
Aber Mainstream ist das Thema noch nicht, das dauert noch ein bisschen.
So und jetzt aber zu einer ganz besonderen CES-Spezialität.
Gadgets, die oft auch unnütz sein können und auch ziemlich lustig aussehen wie Glide, die erste KI-gesteuerte Haarschneidemaschine.
Ähm, Moment, warum genau muss das KI gesteuert sein?
Hä?
Ja, also, ich würde es nicht ausprobieren.
Das sage ich ganz offen.
Aber so in Gadget-Sachen...
Das ist bestimmt eine ganz normale Haarschneidemaschine, nur dass jetzt KI draufgeschrieben wird.
Interessanter fanden wir dieses Blackberry-artige Smartphone namens Communicator mit physischer Tastatur von der Firma Clix.
Die waren bisher für diese Handyhüllen mit so einer angehängten Tastatur bekannt.
Die Idee war an sich ganz cool, aber so ein langgezogenes Handy, das sah auch irgendwie ein bisschen bescheuert aus.
Ich meine, die großen Handys passen jetzt schon kaum in die Hose.
Auf jeden Fall haben die jetzt ihr eigenes Smartphone angekündigt mit einem kleinen, fast quadratischen OLED-Bildschirm und auch einer physischen Tastatur.
Die ist zusätzlich noch berührungsempfindlich und man kann da drüber wischen, um zum Beispiel zu scrollen.
Das Ding wird als Smartphone für Smartphone vermarktet.
Äh, ja, okay.
Also die Idee dahinter ist, dass man den Community...
Es hat ein bisschen was von den alten Blackberry-Dingern, oder?
So ein bisschen, so ein bisschen, ja.
Aber das sind nicht die alten, das sind nicht die alten.
Sowas, sowas eher. Sowas hier eher.
Hat er doch gesagt? Alter, ich bin komplett brain dead, ey.
...Quasi ausschließlich für Kommunikation benutzt und sich dadurch weniger zum Doom-Scrolling verleiten lassen soll.
Einer der Werbeklaims ist auch, designed for doing not Doom-Scrolling.
Okay, also sich ein zweites Smartphone zu kaufen, um weniger am Smartphone zu sein, das ist schon irgendwie ein bisschen verrückt.
Ja, die Idee dahinter muss man mal gucken, da muss man mal testen.
Man kann das Teil eben entweder als Erweiterung zum Haupt-Smartphone verwenden, wie bei einer Smartwatch, oder aber auch natürlich komplett eigenständig, was ich irgendwie interessanter finde.
Denn der Clix Communicator ist ein voll funktionsfähiges Android-Smartphone.
Ja, und da sind natürlich auch Kameras drin, die sind aber jetzt nichts Besonderes.
Was aber besonders ist, ist, dass das Ding einen 3,5 mm Klinkenanschluss hat und hier an der Seite auch noch einen Knopf mit LED, die man einstellen kann.
Also wenn zum Beispiel eine Nachricht von WhatsApp offen ist, dann rollt die grün.
Also ganz ehrlich,
ein zweites Smartphone, dass ich nicht
an mein Smartphone gehe.
Ich benutze das Smartphone
ja auch zum größten Teil eben genau für
sowas, so als Zeitvertreib, wenn ich in der Bahn
sitze und sonst was.
Da will ich ja gerade Reddit und
Twitter und Zeug aufmachen
oder YouTube gucken.
Ich weiß nicht.
Also
und so weiter.
Das gab es ganz früher schon mal und das ist irgendwie immer noch ganz charmant.
Der Clix Communicator kostet im Early-Bird-Preis 399 US-Dollar und soll später im Handel dann 499 US-Dollar kaufen.
Sekunde, Chat. Es gab gerade eine lange Nachricht.
Servus Leute, ich hoffe, mir kann einer kurz helfen. Gucken wir mal.
Mir ist mein System mit NVMe Sandisk Extreme Pro vor ein paar Tagen hops gegangen. Schlecht.
Ich nutze es für OMV plus Jellyfin.
ist das bei den modellen ein bekanntes problem ich habe da noch eine zweite
trau mich nicht diese dafür einsetzen die werbekehre sconing es gab doch mal
nebenbei sandisk das weiß ich nicht samsung hatte mal vor drei jahren oder
so eine ziemliche krepp firma auf ihren ssds drauf
wo die schneller kaputt gegangen sind also bei sandisk weiß ich nicht
Genau, bei Samsung hatten die mal vor drei Jahren oder sowas.
Sandes, keine Ahnung.
Habe ich hier nichts zu sagen.
Europa kommt ist aber leider noch unklar.
Wir bleiben da mal dran.
Clickset ist auch noch das Power-Keyboard angekündigt.
Das ist quasi eine Powerbank, die man hinten an ein Smartphone dran packt.
Ey, wie unhandlich möchte ich mein Smartphone jetzt noch haben eigentlich?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Keyboard angekündigt.
Das ist ja super fett jetzt.
Das ist quasi eine Powerbank, die man hinten an ein Smartphone dran packt
und bei der man dann eine Tastatur ausklappen kann.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eleganter als diese lange Handyhülle mit Keyboard.
Und was ich noch wirklich fand im Ankündigungsvideo,
sagt einer der Gründer am Anfang, dass er schon so viele Keynotes gesehen hat
und sich freut, jetzt mal alles ganz anders zu machen.
Ja, und dann folgt so eine 1 zu 1 Kopie von diesen Standard-Apple-Keynotes,
wo alle alles vom Teleprompter ablesen und aussehen, als würden sie einen Stromschlag kriegen,
wenn sie sich versprechen.
Genau die gleichen Animationen und so wie bei Apple.
Ja, also ist schon irgendwie ein bisschen lustig, aber die Produkte trotzdem ganz interessant.
Müssen wir auch mal testen.
Wenn das Essen nicht rechtzeitig auf dem Tisch steht, könnte es daran liegen,
dass man das Messer nicht aufgeladen hat.
Tja, heutzutage, wie gesagt, ich musste meine Fahrradpedale firmware updaten letztens. Da gibt es auch Smart Knives.
Zumindest wenn man das Ding hier hat. Das ist das C200 Ultrasonic Schneidemesser von Sjell Ultrasonic.
Sieht erstmal aus wie ein stinknormales Messer, aber wenn man diesen orangen Knopf hier drückt, fängt das an zu vibrieren.
Also, ja, wie eine Zahnbürste. Das Ding vibriert über 30.000 Mal pro Sekunde und dadurch soll man laut Hersteller 50% leichter schneiden können.
und Lebensmitteln sollen dadurch auch weniger
an der Klinge kleben bleiben.
Ihr kennt sie ja vielleicht von Knoblauch.
Dabei soll man die Vibrationen weder sehen,
hören noch fühlen. Also im Gegensatz
zu einer elektrischen Zahnbürste.
Im Promomaterial sieht das schon beeindruckend aus,
aber so ein sehr gut geschärftes
Messer schneidet ja auch.
Was für Features haben die smarten Pedale?
Die messen, wie viel
Watt du reintrittst.
Die messen dein Leistungsoutput
auf dem Fahrrad. Das ist eigentlich sehr praktisch.
...
wenn es so leicht angestumpft ist, durch die Vibration weiter so krass schneidet,
muss man auch mal schauen.
Also zumindest wirkt der Hauptentwickler sehr passioniert und stolz auf seine Erfindung.
Und das finde ich ganz sympathisch.
Das Ding kostet einzeln 329 Euro, was sich viel anhört.
Aber wenn man sich ein bisschen in der Welt von Premium-Schneidemessern anschaut,
ist das nicht so teuer.
Der Kram ist teuer, ja.
So Messer-Nerds, die latzen auch mal 1000 Euro pro Messer.
Zusätzlich kann man sie bis auch noch so eine Ladestation in Holzoptik für 119 Euro dazu holen
oder das Ganze im Bundle für 399 Euro bestellen.
Ist also auf jeden Fall eleganter, als immer den Akku rauszuholen und per USB-Kabel zu laden.
Ich bin gespannt, ich glaube, das würde ich auch gerne testen.
Ja und ganz weit oben auf der Liste von Dingen, die man eigentlich nicht braucht,
die ich aber trotzdem haben will, ist dieser super süße Smartphone-Controller.
Das ist das 8BitDo FlipPad und ist ein super kleiner Controller,
der sich per USB-C mit dem Smartphone verbinden lässt.
Der ragt dann etwas über den Bildschirm und hat auch keine Analog-Sticks
und eignet sich aber dafür dann super für Gameboy-Emulatoren.
Da passt ja auch der Formfaktor und das Ding passt eben in die Hosentasche.
Das ist auf jeden Fall transportabler als solche Standard-Smartphone-Controller.
Das hier ist ein Smartphone aus Europa, was ohne Google-Dienste auskommt,
großen Wert auf Datenschutz legt und für das man ein Abo abschließen muss.
Ja, das ist das MC03 von der Schweizer Firma Punkt, mit einem Punkt dahinter.
Und weil das alles so datenschutzmäßig ist, braucht man ein Abo dafür.
Als Wort, mit einem Punkt dahinter.
Ja, das läuft auf dem Betriebssystem AFI, oder AFI, AFI OS.
Und das basiert auf Android AOSP, also der Open Source Version von Android.
Was natürlich ein bisschen lustig ist, wenn man damit wirbt, Google frei zu sein,
aber trotzdem das Google Betriebssystem benutzt.
Aber es laufen eben nicht die Google Dienste.
Der A4OS schreibt sich auch auf die Fahne, auf höchste Datenhoheit und Sicherheit fokussiert zu sein.
Als Beispiel hält man lange auf einer App gedrückt, öffnet sich ein Menü,
SelfishOS, das sagt mir irgendwer. Ist das von LG das? Für die Fernseher?
in der man mit einem Regler das Datenschutzniveau einstellen kann und einen weiteren, wo man den CO2-Fußabdruck regelt, also den Strombedarf.
Ja, CO2-Fußabdruck bei Smartphone-Leistungsaufnahme.
Guck dir so auf meinen Rechner, der im Betrieb 800 Watt wegballert.
Ja, gut, kann man machen.
Auf jeden Fall beim Handy.
Also das Design sieht auf jeden Fall auf den Bildern hier ganz schick aus.
Ein bisschen Schweizer Typografie, Minimalismus und so.
Aber ich müsste das Ding nicht mehr benutzen, um ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, ob das dann auch noch cool aussieht.
Der Haken an der Nummer ist auf jeden Fall, AFIOS gibt es nur im Abo-Modell für 9,99 Euro im Monat.
oder halt für drei Jahre oder fünf Jahre direkt für 199 Euro.
Laut Hersteller werden dafür aber keinerlei Daten gesammelt und verkauft.
Dafür muss man die Entwicklungskosten halt per Abo bezahlen.
Nach dem Motto, wenn du nicht bezahlst, bist du...
Ich glaube, also das ist ja gut gedacht vielleicht, ja, vielleicht auch gut gemacht,
aber ich glaube, es gibt einfach zu wenig Leute, die das anspricht.
Und die dann auch noch ein Abo bezahlen.
Wenn man das MC03 für 699 Euro neu kauft, gibt es aber zumindest ein Jahr umsonst.
Falls euch das übrigens nicht aufgefallen ist in dem Video, das 3003 Team war in diesem Jahr nicht selbst auf der CES, aber wir haben von den Kollegen Florian und André von der CT, die da vor Ort gerade sind, Material bekommen. Danke dafür.
Ja, also schreibt gerne in die Kommentare, welche von den Gadgets hier ihr getestet haben wollt und sagt bitte nicht Boston Dynamics Atlas. Die würde ich zwar auch gerne testen, aber dafür reicht unser Budget nicht und ich glaube, die Dinger kann man auch gar nicht einzeln kaufen.
Da war ja jetzt ja wirklich nichts Spannendes irgendwie dabei, oder?
Wollt ihr noch was gucken? Da hat doch jemand gerade was gepostet. Was ist das denn?
Irgendjemand hat doch hier was mit Microsoft
Microsoft to Microsoft Browser Extension
Was ist das dann?
I made a browser extension that visually changes all
Mention of Microsoft
Was Schwachsinn
Ich hab gedacht Microsoft hat eine Browser Extension wipe coded
Wir refreshen mal YouTube
Ob es jetzt irgendwas gescheites noch gibt
in finnien die gibt es ja auch noch stimmt
der 8
auch lange nichts mehr geguckt
Das haben wir dann hier.
Primary Failed.
Secondary Deleted.
51 Terabyte Gone.
Was kosten eigentlich, wo ich gerade bei Proxmox und gebastelt bin?
Lasst mich gerade mal was gucken.
Was kosten eigentlich...
Was ist denn die größte...
Mal umgedreht.
Was ist denn die größte Festplatte, die es aktuell so gibt?
Für Backup-Stells und sowas.
Hardware Festplatten.
Terabyte meint ihr, nicht Gigabyte.
Hardware Drives.
Was haben wir denn hier? Kapazität ab 28 krass.
sie geht exos 28 terabyte rezertifiziert 30 30 gibt sogar
sie geht ein hof bonus hdd
mal gucken was die beste preis leistung aktuell hat was es gibt ssds mit 128 terabyte was
was ist das hier das kann ich gar nicht
das ist das ist sortiert nach nach preis pro terabyte das wollte ich jetzt wollte ich jetzt
eigentlich hier bei bei geiz als auch mal schnell machen er kann auch hier preis pro terabyte sortiert
ja preis pro terabyte okay die günstigste preis pro terabyte ist aktuell 24 24 tb was ist denn
der unterschied zwischen barak und also hießen die dinger früher immer barak oder versus einwurf
was ist da der unterschied
ASMR
ist SMR
nicht diese geschichte mit überlagerten magnetplatten zeug
Rotationsvibrationssensoren.
Oh, Christ.
Naja, also ganz ehrlich, ich baue die Dinger zwar in den Nass ein,
aber die Einwurf-Nass-Dinger sind ja wahrscheinlich gedacht für den Nass,
wo es die 24-7 betrieben werden.
Bei mir ist es ja so, ich spinne die Platten down
und einmal alle paar Tage, wenn da was draufkommt, müssen die abspinnen.
Exos 28 Terabyte.
Ah, nicht verkehrt.
Seagate, Exos versus, versus Eirol.
Was ist der Unterschied davon?
Wisst ihr warum ich das nicht mache? Weil das einfach sehr viel Strom braucht.
Platten sind jetzt ja, gerade die neuen, sind ja nicht so sparsam, wenn du da drei Stück von hast.
Und wenn die halt im Standby sind, brauchen die fast nix.
Wenn Exos die Enterprise-Klasse für Rechensendung und große Cloud-Speicher darstellen,
dann ist wahrscheinlich die Exos auch die, die am meisten Energie verbrauchen.
Power Consumption.
Ah, nicht.
Okay, also die günstigsten sind wirklich gerade so in dem Dreh irgendwas hier zwischen 24, 28.
Ultrastar.
Warum ist denn die Enterprise Platte so in Anführungsstrichen günstig?
Easy Notebooks Punkt, hab ich noch nie was von gehört.
Moment, rezertifiziert ist gebraucht?
Das ist gebraucht!
Ach so!
Ja, ne, eine gebrauchte Platte möchte ich jetzt nicht unbedingt.
Rezertifiziert?
Da wäre ich nie drauf gekommen, dass das gebraucht bedeutet.
Aber gut, dass der Chat Bescheid weiß.
Also sind die hier wohl gerade preis-leistungsmäßig nicht verkehrt.
Digital Ultra Star.
Hier ist die erste Ironwolf 28 TB.
Kostet einfach mal kleinere ganze Ecke mehr.
Du hast drei Rezertifizierte, aha.
Das heißt, die haben wirklich gebrauchte Festplatten im Einsatz.
Find ich interessant, ja.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich mein,
letztendlich, warum nicht?
In so einem nassen Heim
ist es ja nicht so, dass die krass viel I.O. abkriegen.
Oder Betriebsstunden sammeln.
Die meiste Zeit ist die eh spin down.
Weil das geht schon ins Geld, ja?
Wenn ich mir jetzt beispielsweise zwei Stück hiervon kaufen würde,
dann sind das halt einfach mal 600, also 1300 Euro
für 28 Terabyte.
Also ich rechne jetzt ja da mit Rate 1 an der Stelle.
Aber 28 Terabyte reicht mir halt auch als Speicherplatz, Dicke.
Chat, was würdet ihr machen?
Würdet ihr zur neuen 28 Terabyte Iron Wolf greifen für 650 Euro?
oder
zur rezertifizierten
28 TB Exos
für 100 Euro weniger.
Rezertifiziert
hat nur 6 Monate Garantie.
Äh, ja.
Festplatten, also ich weiß nicht.
Ich hab's bisher selten geschafft,
Festplatten kaputt zu machen.
Neu ich tendiere auch eher zu neu ehrlich gesagt
So und jetzt gucken wir mal gerade just for fun noch wenn wir da gerade schon dabei sind
Festplatten und SSDs solid state drives
solid state drives ich will aber solid state drives formfaktor 2,5 zoll haben
und da ist preis pro terabyte was da das beste
4T, 4TB.
Gibt es da eigentlich auch...
Alter! 64TB, was ist das denn?
15.000 euro 8000 euro
ein schnapper
es ist schon teuer also große ssds sind halt echt hardcore teuer
es kosten die 8 terabyte dinge die sind auch teuer
4 terabyte gehen preis leistungsmäßig halbwegs wir sind auch auch wenn wir hier geguckt haben
sind vier terabyte glaube ich auch preis leistungsmäßig die besten
hat samsung eigentlich noch normale sata platten
ja
KUVO, EVO
870 EVO, 4 TB
ja sowas geht doch, sowas geht doch klar
4 TB
naja
ja KUVO ist Müll, deswegen habe ich nach EVO geguckt
ja ich weiß
generell ist gerade ein schlechter Zeitpunkt Hardware zu kaufen.
SSD-Preise sind hoch, RAM-Preise sind hoch.
SSDs mit Petabyte?
Was haben sie?
Kommen die dann als Kleinwagen?
Das ist irgendeine andere Speicherchip-Technik.
Ich kann es dir aber nicht genau erklären aus dem Kopf,
was der Unterschied ist.
So, dann gucken wir uns das hier mal an.
Primary failed, secondary deleted, 51 Terabyte gone.
Aha, das ist es.
Aber was der Unterschied dazwischen ist, weiß ich auch nicht.
TLC-Speicher versus QLC-Speicher.
Von denen habe ich noch nie was gehört. Kennt ihr die?
Was ist jetzt, wo ich das gerade lese?
Sag mal, was ist eigentlich aus diesen ganzen Leuten da und Plattformen geworden,
wo sie von Twitter abgewandert sind?
Sind ja ganz viele von Twitter abgewandert und die sind dann zu Masterdon oder wie das hieß.
Ist da überhaupt noch irgendjemand aktiv?
Geht da überhaupt irgendwas?
Letztendlich ist nach wie vor Twitter das, wo halt die meisten Leute sind
und wo noch irgendwas los ist in der Richtung.
Klar, okay, oh.
X formerly known as Twitter.
Ich krieg richtig krass Hunger gerade.
Master Don Analytics?
Aha, was ist das denn?
Mal kurz gucken.
Aber guck mal, Users steigt, Active Users sinkt.
Das ist auch interessant.
Threads ist Facebook.
Meter.
Guck mal, 758.000
Active Users, das ist halt nix.
Okay, weiter.
like? What's the format of the messages?
Or what's encryption look like?
Or why do I even exist?
Du greifst dir gerade Boobitos rein.
Excellent.
...must offer a very compelling use case, as the real-time chat
competition is pretty stiff.
Why not just use WhatsApp or Slack or
DingTalk? Well, those are
centralized platforms, meaning a big
company like Metabook or Slack
owns your chat history and will make you pay
for it.
Ich bin stolz drauf, dass ich kein WhatsApp-Account habe.
Ich habe mich erfolgreich seit 15 Jahren
oder wie lange es das gibt, davor gedrückt.
Anyone, for example Element themselves, Mozilla or the German military can spin up their own
Matrix home server and begin messaging away.
But just like how Gmail dominates the email market, the majority of Matrix user traffic
is also centralized in large public home servers, the biggest of which is also the oldest, called
the matrix.org home server.
This was the original reference server set up by the creators as an easy entry point
for using Matrix.
Und als die Community wuchs, wurde es im Grunde die default-Server, die alle zusammengebracht haben.
Zurück zu Element-Kreationen.
Ihre Ingenieure waren verantwortlich für das Run-Aus der Matrix.org-Homeserver.
Sie haben Servern von einer seltenen Firma namens Mythic Beasts gerent, und ran-Synapse
Das klingt ja sehr Business Enterprise-mäßig.
auf dem, was die Premiere-Matrix-Homeserver-Software ist, die von Element selbst hergestellt wird.
Synapse rettet fast alles, wie Raum-State, Events, Messungen und Accounts in Postgres,
Das ist auch so ein Ding, wo ich mich gerne mal mit beschäftigen würde, weil ich da überhaupt keinen Plan von habe.
Das ist, wie man eine Postgres-Datenbank ordentlich hochverfügbar macht.
Ich bin mich nie großartig mit beschäftigt, interessiert mich aber.
Also ich glaube, das Beste ist, was man bei Datenbanken macht, also das Beste und Einfachste bei Datenbanken ist, dass du einen, also keine Ahnung, du hast fünf Datenbanken, die sind read-only im Endeffekt und nur eine Datenbank ist schreibbar und die synkt dann halt die Changes überall hin.
So ist das glaube ich die einfachste Variante, dass du quasi eine hast, die schreibt und der Rest ist read-only.
Das habe ich aber noch nie eingerichtet.
the primary to replicate its changes the walls were also archived on amazon's
simple storage service for backup and restore purposes this kind of database setup is quite
common in fact gitlab which we covered a while ago used the same setup in 2017 except in today's
case the primary database is called db2 and the secondary database is called db1 anyway
Element sah, dass der Database-Server
Lass mich raten, DB1 war mal die einzige.
hat 90% Kapazität erreicht,
bei 51 TB Disk-Ausgabe.
Also war es Zeit für einen Upgrade.
Um 11.03 Uhr,
hat MythicBeast zwei extra NVMe-Drives
zu DB2, der Primär,
und DB1, der Zweiter, geöffnet.
14 Minuten später
gab es eine Drive zu DB2, der Primär,
und DB1, der Zweiter.
14 Minuten später
wurde ein externer Drive
mysteriös aus dem DB2-Rate-Array ausgeschlossen.
Das war nicht so ungewöhnlich, da ein neues Gerät ein Rescan aller Geräte triggeren kann.
Also können existierende Geräte offline fallen, wenn es an Verbindungen zu tun hat.
Aber weil DB2 das Redundanz-Rate von independent disks Level 10 oder RAID 10 oder RAID 1 plus 0 oder Mirroring plus Striping benutzt hat,
1 plus 0 ist die beste Schreibweise, finde ich.
Da kann man sich nämlich merken, in welcher Reihenfolge das ist.
Chat, die Fisis im Chat, wer hat aufgepasst?
Wie viele Platten dürfen bei einem Raid 1.0 kaputt gehen, minimal und maximal?
also wie viel dürfen mindestens kaputt gehen dass es noch geht und wie viel gehen im best
case so max 2 mit 1 korrekt alle schnell gegoogelt ja ja das richtig chat ihr habt
ihr habt recht, High-IQ-Chat schlägt wieder zu.
Excellent, excellent.
Übrigens, wenn ihr euch...
Wartet mal.
Mal was gucken.
Was ist das?
Übrigens, wenn euch der Stream gefällt,
was ich sagen wollte,
könnt ihr mir auch gerne ein Follow dalassen.
Vielleicht machen wir heute Mittag sogar weiter mit Proxmox und dann Onstream.
Oder ein bisschen Rust programmieren wieder, ich bin mir nicht sicher, was ich heute mehr
Bock habe.
... aber jetzt, dass diese Toleranz genutzt wurde, war es nicht mehr sicher, DB2 in Service zu halten.
Diese Situation ist, weshalb Element DB1, der zweite Database, hatte.
At 12.57 the engineers began shifting customer traffic to DB1 before taking DB2 down for maintenance.
A cool 30 minutes later the traffic shift was complete.
Yay, now DB1 was actually the primary.
But there was a catch.
Due to some bug in the archiving script, DB1 was not saving any backups.
Was wird mit Proxmox gemacht?
Was ich vorhabe ist, ich habe ja bei mir aktuell einen HP Microserver mit Android drauf,
paar Container, paar VMs.
ich bin damit nicht so richtig glücklich und ich wollte mir einfach mal
Proxmox angucken, ob das vielleicht
was ist mit ein bisschen
mehr, da muss ich ein bisschen mehr basteln vielleicht
aber was, was mir besser gefällt
also letztendlich wird es wahrscheinlich drauf rauslaufen
dass ich da eine VM drin
laufen habe mit DocPloy, wo meine ganzen
Docker-Container reinkommen
irgendwie 1, 2 LXC-Container
laufen habe auf Proxmox, die dann so
Basic-Sachen machen wie Monitoring
zum Beispiel
und Zabbix
und
VM für Home Assistant.
Da muss ich halt gucken, wie man das mit Backups macht.
Und auch wie man,
wie ich dann da mein
Samba irgendwie drauf kriege.
Das wahrscheinlich dann auch in einem Container,
in einem LXT-Container.
Ich muss mir das mal angucken.
Proxmox hat auch einen Backup-Server.
Ja, den brauche ich nicht.
Backup werde ich wieder relativ easy machen.
Also was ich gesehen habe, ist, es gibt eine
Möglichkeit, direkt
in Proxmox, dass man sagt,
quasi jede Nacht
um 3 Uhr
macht der einen Backup
von allen Containern, allen
VMs.
Und
dann werde ich das einfach
ersunken auf eine externe Platte und gut ist.
Ja.
Willst du ja auch neue Hardware zulegen?
Ja, da bin ich mir noch nicht ganz sicher.
Also entweder benutze ich den Microserver weiter.
Weil das Ding ist ja, ich habe einen Microserver mit, glaube ich, 64 GB oder 32 GB.
Kauf mal aktuell 32 GB, Alter.
Das ist halt teuer.
Und das Ding geht noch.
Ich habe da, glaube ich, 12 oder 14 TB Platten drin.
Aber nur zwei Stück.
Raid 1.
Ähm.
Ich bin grad noch am überlegen.
Also ich, ich, ich schiele ja
ein bisschen auf
so einen, äh, Ukraine-NAS
mit, äh,
vier oder sechs, äh, Slots.
Und da halt
Proxmox dann drauf. Ich, ich muss
auch gucken ich bin mir auch gar nicht sicher ob ich das jetzt weiterhin so laufen lassen wie es
jetzt ist weil ich habe ich habe die letzten jahre über schon ein bisschen angefangen das
alles ein bisschen zu entzerren das nicht mehr alles auf einer kiste läuft ja ich bin mir
beispielsweise auch am überlegen ob ich mein home assistant nicht tatsächlich auf dem raspberry pi
packe mein haus ist es auf dem raspberry pi packe und nicht mehr auf meinem server laufen lassen ich
muss mal gucken mal gucken wie ich das wie ich das so ein teile und bastler
alles ich hab's ja nicht eilig ich habe hier meine mein micro server mit android
drauf der macht ja auch alles
ein minis forum n5 pro zeigt mal her
eine frau ki warum ist da was hat es mit ki bitte schön zu tun
Warum muss da KI drin sein?
Das schreckt mich.
Der Krümel, danke schön für den Sub.
Box Subscription.
Ach, wegen der CPU, okay.
Aber Chat, wie geht es euch eigentlich?
Ich bin mittlerweile schon richtig triggert,
wenn ich irgendwo das Wort AI oder KI sehe.
Weil ich denke, die patten das halt einfach überall drauf.
Mittlerweile ist es eher so,
dass es für mich dazu führt, dass ich was nicht kaufe,
nur weil KI und AI draufstehen.
Der Tasche hinzufügen.
Okay, 96 Gig DDR5 ECC kostet was?
Äh.
So ein Preis wäre nett.
So eine Preisanzeige hätte was.
Okay, der Tasche hinzufügen.
EU, Euro.
Das geht eigentlich sogar noch irgendwie halbwegs klar.
Ja, ne?
Ein 96-Gig, das ist super krass.
So viel braucht man eigentlich gar nicht.
Was kostet denn der...
der Tasche hinzufügen?
Ach, Moment. Moment. Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das ist nur Bare Bones plus...
Ach so.
Ich dachte, das wäre das mit...
Weil ich habe schon gedacht, das ist super günstig eigentlich.
Ach so, das ist ohne alles.
Das kostet gleich 2000 Euro.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Barebone kostet gleich hier fast gleich wie 16 GB.
Und wie sieht es da so aus mit?
Also was ich bei dem jetzt halt schon irgendwie merkwürdig finde, wenn es für nass ist, warum
hast du?
Doch, hast du mal gesagt, warum hast du keine Wechsel Dingsbums Platten?
davor.
Aber hast du anscheinend.
Muss man vorne dann irgendwie abmachen
oder wie geht das?
Warum hat das Ding da unten eine Schublade?
Wofür ist denn diese Schublade da unten?
Wow.
Was ist das?
Da unten, das ist der PC.
Find ich eigentlich ganz cool.
Ich schreib mir das mal kurz auf hier.
Find ich eigentlich ganz nice.
Hat das ein 10-Gig-Netzwerk?
Ah ja, hier.
Oh, hat doch was.
Wie viele sind das? Fünf Stück.
Fünf ist eigentlich genau die richtige Anzahl.
Da kann ich zwei oder drei HDDs reinmachen und ein RAID 1 SSD.
Eigentlich ganz gut.
Man könnte, also mit drei Platten kann man tatsächlich auch mal über einen RAID 5 nachdenken.
Muss ich mir überlegen.
Das hat 5 HDD-Base
plus 2 bis 3 SSDs
Ja Moment
Auf dem Mainboard NVMe-SSDs
oder wie?
Ah hier, 3, 3, M2
Was sind denn
U2-SSDs?
sind die ganzen
Hä?
Aha.
Aber das wusste ich gar nicht,
dass das gibt.
Aha.
Siehst du mal,
ernt man nicht aus.
Ja, eigentlich...
Was kostet denn aktuell jetzt mal so ganz, wo wir gerade dabei sind?
Hardware?
RAM?
Sekunde, Leute, mal kurz was gucken.
Gucken, gucken.
RAM?
DDR5?
Speicher?
Alter, der Scheiß ist ja teuer geworden mittlerweile.
Preis pro Gig.
Das ist das günstigste zur Zeit.
Es ist schon nicht ohne
Gucken wir mal
32 Gig, das reicht
32 Gig
Bezahlst du schon ganz gut was
Da bezahlst du schon echt nicht schlecht
Wir haben es nicht ohne.
Aber gut,
finde ich nicht übel hier.
Der ist ohne ECC.
Ja, aber ECC-RAM muss nicht unbedingt sein.
Ich hoffe, das sehen jetzt die
ZFS-Trunas-Fans nicht,
dass ich gesagt habe, muss kein ECC-RAM sein.
Da flippen die aus.
Was? ZFS ohne ECC-RAM?
Wir können gerade mal gucken, was
was
ECC-RAM kostet.
Kann man das hier auswählen?
Chat, wo kann man hier ECC-RAM auswählen?
Geht das gar nicht, oder?
In der Mitte war was mit LCC?
Mit ECC?
Ah, hier!
Hier!
Okay.
DDR4
DDR4 ist deutlich günstiger als DDR5
DDR5
Alter
Das geht schon ganz gut ins Gelde
Erweiterter Filter oben.
Ah.
Äh.
Was ist denn Sideband ECC?
Ich habe keinen Plan.
Aber das ist doch gar nicht mit ECC hier, oder? Das ist non-ECC.
Ne, das war schon richtig, was ich da hatte.
Udim ECC
Aber warum gibt es da kaum was?
ECC
Na, das geht doch jetzt eigentlich ganz gut klar, oder?
16 gig 182
teuer
ach wurscht ich werde mal gucken ich werde mal gucken was ich mir da kaufe
soll das video fertig ist probleme sound kind of hashtag scary to the engineers
so die des leiter start replikieren traffic to the b2 effektiv mit turning
Wie lange hat das gedauert?
Das Ding hat einfach mal 4 Stunden Reboot.
was dann rebooting. Not only did the drive not come back online, but his second drive
also went missing, causing the RAID array to fail to assemble. So the server ended
up booting into recovery mode, meaning it was basically completely inoperational. They
Sie sind zurück in Square One, außer DB2 wurde jetzt noch mehr zerstört.
Aber der Chaos hat gerade angefangen.
Etwa eine Stunde und eine halbe später haben sie die Erklärung erreicht, dass die Raid-Array
auf DB2 und all seinen Inhalten für gut weggegangen ist.
Also haben sie in den folgenden Stunden eine neue, frische DB2-Instanz vorbereitet, um
von Backup zu retten.
Sie haben auch den Bug, der DB1 von den Wänden zu S3 verhindern hat, geschlossen, um die
Backups auf der Zeit zu haben.
Die hatten immerhin Glück, dass DB2 weiter funktioniert, ne?
tool called wuaji which also supported incremental backups containing only changes since the previous
backup so ssh onto db2 they ran backup list to find the most recent backup which is a chain
including both the base backup and incremental backups then they ran backup fetch to extract
that backup to a target directory just to make things convenient they targeted the standard
postgres data directory the output of the command was also written to a log file for debugging
However, the backup fetch command failed.
This was because the engineer at some point changed their shell directory to the data
directory.
When you write output to a file like this, the output file obviously needs to be created
before the command executes.
So restore.log was created in the data directory since that's where the command was run from.
Then backup fetch ran, which based on the code will verify that its target directory
is empty.
Since the directory had this random log file in it, the command failed.
Problem, the engineers could simply switch to the home directory and run the command from there.
This way restore.log will be created in the home directory instead and everything would be good.
They ran the command again and it failed again. Haha, rookie mistake. They didn't delete the
restore.log file created in the data directory from the first run. So the target directory
Jetzt löschen sie bestimmt zu viel.
still wasn't empty.
No problem, I got this.
Someone said from the other side of the room,
Ich werde die Kontente der Datendirektorie auswählen.
Das sollte natürlich gut sein, da der Server offline ist.
Der Ingenieur hat seinen ganzen Being auf seinen Laptop-Screen gefokust.
Ziel kaputt gemacht und muss gestorrt werden.
Oh ne, jetzt lockt er sich auf die falsche Kiste eingleich, hä?
Ja.
Ich werde es einfach auf der Show-Session auswählen, die ich vorne habe, und sehen, was passiert.
Er hat die Befehle eingeschaltet, um die Files in der Daten-Directory zu entfernen, und hat sie verwendet.
Und er hat bemerkt, dass es eine überraschend lange Zeit dauerte.
Das war ein bisschen seltsam, also hat er die Befehle ausgelöst, um es zu verhindern.
Aber es war zu spät.
Er hat die Befehle auf DB1, der neuen In-Service-Primary, verwendet.
F.
Nicht DB2, die originelle Primär, die sie versuchen, zu restaurieren.
Der ganze Service muss geschlossen werden, offiziell den Matrix.org Home Server offline nehmen.
Es war 6 Uhr, als das passiert ist, und die Ingenieure haben die Datenpartition von DB1 schnell wieder auf dem Read gemountet, um weitere Schadenswerte zu vermeiden, in der Lage, dass sie von Datenrecovering-Tools verwendet werden können.
Nach dem Zeitraum, um ihre Optionen zu überlegen, haben sie beschlossen, dass sie nur weitergehen sollten, was sie vorher gemacht haben, nämlich von ihren S3-Backups zu restaurieren.
So this time, they correctly set up the empty Postgres-Data-Directory on DB2
and once again ran BackupFetch to restore to the latest daily backup.
Transferring 51 Terabytes of data was gonna take a while,
so it was time to kick back and enjoy the fact that if Matrix was functioning as intended,
being a decentralized protocol, the server outage shouldn't really impact anyone.
Rise and shine, and it was now 7.21 the next morning.
Data extraction from the weekly base backup was complete.
However, as soon as Wall-G started to restore the daily incremental backups, it immediately failed.
This was due to a known bug in Wall-G that had already received a fix.
Element had previously encountered this bug on their regular backup recovery tests,
but they only updated Wall-G to fix the bug on their test servers, not the actual production servers.
Updating Wall-G now and rerunning Backup Fetch would mean downloading the entire 51TB again,
So the engineers decided to patch Wall-G to accept a non-empty data directory with the base backup and to skip straight to the incremental backups.
About two hours later, all the incremental backups were fully restored and they were ready to replay the walls.
The playback rate was slower than expected.
There were 18 hours of transactions in the walls and replaying these took another five and a half hours.
By four in the afternoon, they finally had a working database instance with no data loss.
Jetzt war es nur noch ein Thema, Synapse wieder aufzunehmen und den Home-Server online zu bringen.
Um 6 Uhr, 24 Stunden nach der Ausstattung und 31 Stunden nach der initialen Hardware-Fall, war Matrix.org wieder.
Aber ihr Arbeit war noch nicht fertig. Nur DB2 war im Service. DB1 war noch da, halb verlost.
Aber die europäischen Ingenieure waren müde.
Also war es Zeit, zu schlafen, während ihr ein amerikanisches SRE die Kabel auf alles gehalten hat, um sicherzustellen, dass ihr einziges Database-Setup nicht verhäuert.
Back to work at 9am London time, they encountered a few minor hiccups in restoring DB1,
but soon enough they copied over the data from DB2 and set it to replicating.
So what can we learn?
During the outage, problems arose when the engineers had to go off script from their runbooks due to their commands failing.
There are various ways to make the commands more bulletproof,
such as outputting restore.log to an absolute path rather than its current relative path.
Das stimmt wohl, ja.
Das wird nicht funktionieren.
over the network, I suppose there's nothing that can be done about slow transfer speeds.
Or is there?
What if on top of backing up data to the cloud, we also back up locally on the database instance
itself?
At first glance, this seems crazy.
Does taking a backup mean copying my entire database to another folder?
That's literally going to take forever and explode my disk usage.
Well, file systems like CFS use special tactics to take snapshots of the entire disk.
Das stimmt, ZFS-Snapshots sind erstmal, wenn du sie machst, 0 Byte groß.
Die werden erst größer, wenn sich was ändert.
Hat dein NAS genauso schnelle Ladezeiten?
Vorschau von Bildern.
Ich habe da keine Google Drive Alternative drauflaufen.
Ich mache da eigentlich nur Backups drauf.
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Irgendwie war ich damals froh, dass ich kein ZFS mehr habe.
Sache weniger, um das man sich kümmern muss.
Jetzt bin ich gerade am überlegen, eigentlich wäre ZFS doch mal wieder cool.
Vielleicht baue ich mir doch eine Proxmox-Kiste und stelle das da drauf um bei mir daheim.
aber der Snapshot wird weiterhin die originalen Referenzen bezeichnen.
So kann man, wenn man die Datenbank unvergleichbar verlässt,
einfach nur durch...
Also TrueNAS hat mir nicht so gut gefallen.
...
... das Live-File-System verbessern, um an den Block-Tree eines vorherigen Snapshots zu bemerken.
Und du bist fertig. Kein Downloaden und kein Kopieren.
Nur dafür, dass du noch weitere externen Backups hast,
in der Falle, dass der ganze Server verfehlt wird.
Das ist etwas, was King's College London so hart lernen musste.
Jetzt müssen wir abschreiten.
Exzellent.
Leute, ich hab Hunger.
Ich geh jetzt was essen.
Gerade ist die größte Technikmesse der Welt in Las Vegas
zu Ende gegangen. Es gab...
Okay, das hab ich überhaupt nicht gestartet.
Was meinst du?
macht dir keine Schmerzen unter Proxmox?
Spaghetti, korrekt.
Kein Lachsnudel mit Lachs.
Hast du Empfehlungen für einen 2,5 Gig
Managed Switch?
Nicht wirklich.
Ich habe hier einen.
Das ist aber kein 2,5 Gig.
Das wird es dir nicht bringen.
Ich habe hier einen
Switch mit 8 Gigabit
und 2 mal 10 Gig. Das ist halt nicht das.
MikroTik hat auch erstaunlich wenig in dieser Richtung, muss man sagen.
MikroTik ist ja, was preis-leistungsmäßig angeht, immer mein Lieblingshersteller.
Wir können mal gucken, aber die haben erstaunlich wenig 2,5 Gig Sachen.
Gucken wir mal hier, Switches.
Was hat er denn? Der CRS 3010, aber der hat doch auch nur, ja genau, 8 Gig und 2 mal SFP+.
Das bringt ja nix.
Wir suchen mal hier 2,5 Ethernet.
Mindestens.
Aha.
Ah, guck mal.
Ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Wie viele Ports hat der?
Ports
Ah, ey, das ist richtig gut
Das ist richtig gut
Okay, den würde ich mir wahrscheinlich auch kaufen, wenn ich sowas bräuchte
Geht auch preis-leistungsmäßig
Voll klar
Kann man nicht auf die Router-OS-Dinge
Auch immer Switch-OS drauf machen
Weiß ich nicht
Okay, das ist jetzt ein bisschen übertrieben alles.
20, 20.
Das ist aber nicht schlecht, ganz ehrlich.
8,2,5, 2,10 Gig als Uplink.
Was hat der für eine
CPU?
2x 800 MHz
Okay, damit kannst du sogar
ein bisschen
ein bisschen Routing-Funktionalität
und Firewall-Geschichten und so benutzen
im Heimbereich
Das geht auch
ganz gut, kannst du sogar noch ein bisschen mehr machen als nur
Switch
Der hat leider nur einen Lüfter
Das meinst du, der ist laut?
Aber 219 Dollar
Also ganz ehrlich, ich finde das klingt eigentlich ganz gut
174 Euro
Das ist doch, also ganz ehrlich
Finde ich nicht schlecht
Zur Not kann man die Lüfter ja austauschen noch
Ja, Schreibtisch könnte zu laut sein, falls du ihn auf den Schreibtisch stellen willst.
Was ist das für ein MikroTik? Ich glaube, die kommen aus Polen oder so.
Aber ich habe viele MikroTik-Geräte. Also für mich ist das die beste Preis-Leistungs-Marke, wenn es um Netzwerkequipment geht.
Die sind auch relativ verbreitet, also das ist jetzt gar nicht so unbekannt.
oder Litauen, ja.
Wie viel zieht das Watt im Eidl?
Müsste gucken, weiß ich nicht.
Aber die sind relativ sparsam.
So, Leute.
Ich geh jetzt was essen.
Ich hab übertrieben Hunger.
Vielleicht sehen wir uns heute Mittag noch einmal.
Macht's gut. Schön, dass ihr dabei wart.
Wenn es euch gefallen hat, Follow da lassen.
Wir sehen uns. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.